WILL COME TO ORDER A GOOD
AFTERNOON- I AM CENTER DAVE
CORTEZ HE'LL BE TAKING OVER THE
DUTIES IS TERRIBLE CENTER
WINNERS OUT IN I WANT TO
WELCOME A NEW MEMBER ON OUR
COMMITTEE TODAY SENATOR AIKMAN
THINKS ENTERTAINMENTS HERE
SHE'S NOT SHE WILL BE- IN
RESPONSE TO THE COPA NINETY
NUMBERS SEEM TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS ENDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING A
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
LOVE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS HELLO. WILL
REQUIRE IT WILL BE USING THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHICH
TESTIFIED TODAY. OR FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. A REPEAT
THAT. 877-336-4437 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT. AGAIN
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS.%
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
WEBSITE FOR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. PURPOSES ONLY ONE
TIME. IN PLEASE WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN SOMETIMES
BE A SHORT WEEK. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTED ANYWHERE THEN READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARINGS ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. THIS IS IMPORTANT IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I'LL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEANING
SERVICE OR HAVE THE CONNECTIONS
NEEDED. WELL EVERY EFFORT IS
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW US OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGY. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL. SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
SIXTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WHICH WE HEAR AND FOLLOW ORDERS
BEFORE WE HEAR A PRESENTATION
ON THOSE BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM LET US CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
COURTESY COURTESY PRESENT BATES.
BATES PRESENT COPYRIGHT.
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT PRESENT
EGGMAN. MCGUIRE A CHILL BOOK A
CHOPPER PRESENT SCANNER NUMBER
NUMBER PRESENT WHAT KASKY
CASKET PRESENT. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU BUT BEFORE WE
HEAR FROM THE AUTHORS WILL TAKE
UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR IT
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS. TWO SIX
SEVEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND
SIXTEEN IS THERE A MOTION ON
CONSENT. THE MOTION FROM
SENATOR CAFIERO- CONSULTANT-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS
OF FILE ITEMS. TO SIX SEVEN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
SENATOR CORTESE. CORTEZ CI
BATES HI BATES- CUBBY RO
COPYRIGHT EGGMAN EGGMAN HI
REQUIRE A CHILLED BULK. SKINNER
NUMBER. NUMBER FIVE CASKEY WITH
CASKEY I. SIX SIX WE HAVE SIX I
BOATS NO NO VOTES EIGHT AND
NINE WE WILL PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR
FIRST AUTHOR I UNDERSTAND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN IS
PRESENT. YOUR. OKAY I AM NEW TO
CHEERING IN THIS ROOM SO I WAS
LOOKING EVERYWHERE BUT WHERE I
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE LOOKING FOR
SOME REMEMBER- IF YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL THIS
IS AB FORTINO ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MEMBERS
IT'S NOT OFTEN THAT WE CAN TALK
ABOUT A POLICY THAT IMPACTS SO
MANY OF OUR GOALS WE ALL HAVE A
GOAL OF SUPPORTING SMALL
BUSINESS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THEY NEED TO OPERATE. CHANGE
USES. FOR PROPERTY OWNERS TO
DECIDE WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
TENANTS WITHOUT. UNDUE
INTERFERENCE FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE ALL HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THE GOAL OF GETTING
PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS
CREATING. SOME DENSER MORE
WALKABLE BIKEABLE CITY CENTERS
PARTICULARLY NEAR TRANSIT.
WHICH AS A STATE WE HAVE MADE
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF INVESTMENT IN. WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT TRYING TO
MAKE TRANSIT WORK BETTER BY
TRYING TO ATTRACT MORE HOUSING
AND MORE BUSINESSES NEAR THOSE
VERY SAME HIGH QUALITY TRAIN
STOPS. AND HIGH QUALITY BUS
STOPS. WE TALK PARTICULARLY
ABOUT HOUSING ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF CREATING MORE
HOUSING NOT JUST HOUSING FOR.
THE WEALTHY THE HOUSING FOR.
THE ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
IN FOR THE MISSING MIDDLE.
ABOUT FINDING WAYS OF BRINGING
BUILDING COSTS DOWN NOW A LOT
OF THE BUILDING COST THAT WE
HAVE HAVE TO DO WITH THINGS
THAT WE WANT BUILDERS TO SPEND
MONEY ON. LIKE EARTHQUAKE
SAFETY LIKE ENVIRONMENTAL. A
STANDARDS IN BUILDINGS AND YET
THERE ARE STILL SOME
REQUIREMENTS THAT MOST OF OUR
CITIES HAVE THAT ADD TREMENDOUS
COST TO THE COST OF HOUSING.
BUT ENDS UP GETTING SPREAD
DIRECTLY BACK TO TENANTS
KEEPING THAT HOUSING COSTS HI.
NO APARTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
GENERALLY HAVE TO INCLUDE ONE
OR TWO OR EVEN MORE SPACES PER
UNIT. AND COMMERCIAL PROPERTIES
OFTEN HAVE TO PROVIDE ONE SPACE
FOR EVERY ONE TO TWO HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET OF OFFICE SPACE
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THAT
BUILDING MIGHT HAPPEN TO BE AND
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE AT THAT
PARTICULAR TENANT. THIS ONE
SIZE FITS ALL MANDATES IS OFTEN
IMPOSED IN THE AREAS EVEN THAT
ARE VERY CLOSE TO OUR HIGHEST
QUALITY TRANSIT. THIS CREATES A
SITUATION WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ENTICED TO DRIVE RATHER THAN
USE THAT VERY TRANSIT WE'RE
JOINED IN PARKING LOTS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR PEOPLE TO WALK
AND BIKE PLEASANTLY AROUND
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS. WHICH OF
COURSE CONTINUES TO INVITE MORE
MORE CONGESTION RIGHT INTO
THOSE VERY SAME TRANSIT
ADJACENT AREAS. MANDATORY
PARKING REQUIREMENTS ALSO
WORSEN CALIFORNIA'S SEVERE
HOUSING CRISIS BY RAISING THE
COST OF HOUSING PRODUCTION. ON
AVERAGE A GARAGE COSTS TWENTY
FOUR TO THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER SPACE TO BUILD
WHICH IS PASSED DIRECTLY TO THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE RENTING.
THOSE UNITS. AND ONSITE SIDE
PARKING OFTEN TAKES UP SPACE
THAT COULD OTHERWISE BE USED
FOR MORE UNITS. NOWWHAT
HAPPENS IF IN THOSE AREAS YOU
WILL ALLOW THE MARKET TO DECIDE
HOW MUCH PARKING THEY NEED FOR
THEIR PARTICULAR DEVELOPMENT.
C. N. B. A. GO ELIMINATED
MINIMUM PARKING REQUIREMENTS IN
THEIR TRANSIT PRIORITY AREAS IN
APRIL TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
AND TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THE
CITY SAW MORE THAN FOUR TIMES
INCREASE FOUR TIMES INCREASE IN
AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT WERE
CREATED. WE CANNOT CONCLUDE
THAT A 100% OF THE ELIMINATION
OF PARKING REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
THIS INCREASE IN PRODUCTION BUT
WE CAN CONCLUDE THAT IT DID NOT
HURT THE DENSITY BONUS
PRODUCTION. AB FORTINO ONE DOES
NOT PROHIBIT ANYONE FROM ADDING
PARKING IT SIMPLY ALLOWS
DEVELOPERS TO RIGHT SIZE
PARKING FOR THEIR DEVELOPMENTS.
AND IN BUFFALO NEW YORK WHICH
ELIMINATED PARKING REQUIREMENTS
CITY WIDE ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO
WHAT THEY SAW WAS THAT
DEVELOPERS WHO WERE DOING
PARTICULARLY MIXED USE HOUSING.
WORK TOGETHER TO CREATE PARKING
THAT THEY WERE SHARED BETWEEN
THOSE UNITS MAYBE THEY CREATED
TANDEM PARKING STUDENT PARKING
WAS ADDING ONE UNIT ONE PARKING
SPACE INSTEAD OF TWO BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THEY KNEW THE
STUDENTS NEEDED. WE TOOK A
MOMENT IN GOVERNMENT FINANCE
THAT NARROWED THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL SO THAT IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN SMALLER
COMMUNITIES. IT'S THE BUSTED
LINES ARE NOT AFFECTED AND THAT
NEAR RAIL IT'S ONLY A QUARTER
MILE AS OPPOSED TO HALF A MILE
LIKE IN THE URBAN AREAS. WE THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES A CONTINUED
PARKING ACCESS FOR DISABLED.
RESIDENTS AND FOR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING. EIGHTY FORTY
NO ONE IS ALSO THE REAR BILL
THAT BRINGS MANY DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER. MANY OF
MEMBERS OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY ARE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL ALONG WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WHO SEES THE
IMPORTANCE FOR RESTAURANTS FOR
BUILDERS. AND ALSO OF COURSE-
HOUSING ADVOCATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA YIMBY AND SPURRED
ABUNDANT HOUSING LA WHO ARE
SPONSORS. THE BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIPHATE BY BY C. B. I.
A. BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP. THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL TELEVISION CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE NATIONAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN RTC. THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND TRANSFORM.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OR
COUNCIL MEMBERS ACTUAL TEN FROM
GIL ROY. AND MIA KANG THE
SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT OF
RELATED CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT
I. CERTAINLY WOULD APPRECIATE.
YOUR I VOTED IN SUPPORT. FOR
THIS VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO B.
MEMBER. YET AGAIN I UNDERSTAND
THE YOUR LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS-
THE FIRST ONE IS ACREE HILTON-
AND WILL ANSWER CRUCIAL INTO.
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE AT THIS
TIME. HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBER
STAFF ABOUT AFTER THE PUBLIC
AND DOCTOR THING RESIDENT IF
YOU ARE A CALIFORNIA. ARE YOU
GUYS ARE GONNA BE BACK. WE'RE
HEARING YOU BUT- THERE IS- A
LITTLE BREAK UP OR PAUSE IN
BETWEEN SO IF YOU CAN JUST TRY
TO PROCEED WITH YOUR COMMENTS
WILL LET YOU KNOW IF THERE'S
ANY PROBLEM. THANK YOU I AM
JACK WELL DONE READY TO GO
RIGHT OUT AND IT GOES TO THE
COUNCIL MEMBER EITHER CROSS
CALIFORNIA HAD MANY EXAMPLES OF
PROPERTIES WERE USED TO NOT
REQUIRE PARKING MANY DECADES
AGO BEFORE THE MAJORITY OF THE
OWNING CODESHAVE BEEN ADOPTED
THAT REQUIRE MORE LAND TO BE
DEVELOPED FOR PARKING WITH THE
RECENT IMPLEMENTATION OF
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED WE LOOK
TOWARDS INCREASING ALTERNATIVE
OPTIONS IN A SINGLE OCCUPANT
VEHICLE AND CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
LIKE AB FORTINO ONE TO CONTINUE
TO PUSH US OR- IN RESPONSE. AND
MAKE. AND THE CLOSURE OF
RESTAURANT AND SHOPS LOCAL.
HAVE ALLOWED. BUSINESSES YOU
EXPAND INTO YOU ON FIGHTING
STREET PARKING SPACE INTO A
LOCKER ST DOCTOR DINING
SHOPPING. NEW MARKET I COULD
USE THE PARKING SPACES HAVE
SHOWN US THE WAY FORWARD TO
CREATE MORE INVITING
SUSTAINABLE NEIGHBORHOODS AND
ALLOW SMALL BUSINESSES TO
SERVE. YOU SURVIVE. IN IT
SOMETIMES DIDN'T THRIVE. WITH
THE RECENT OUT A GALLERY
GENERAL TWENTY. WE CALL FROM
ACTION THAT IT. CONTINUING TO
PROMOTE CLEANER MODES OF
TRANSPORTATION. ENCOURAGING
FIFTEEN A PROPOSED DEVELOPMENTS
TO INCORPORATE TRANSPORTATION
DEMAND MANAGEMENT MEASURES SUCH
AS CAR SHARING TREND POP IN. AN
UNBUNDLING OF PARKING WE HAVE
PLANNED FOR PROJECTS LIKE THIS
AND HAVE READ RESOURCES IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO MAKE THEM
SUCCESSFUL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THE PARKING LOT ACTUALLY AND
THE DO NOT THE BIRTH OF THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO BE ABLE TO
MAXIMIZE OUR COLLECTION OF
PROPERTY TAXES. AND A MIXED USE
PROJECT WILL GENERATE
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY INTEL
STOCK. WHEN TRANSIT RIDERSHIP
THERE MODE INTO GETTING TO
TRANSIT BY WALK BIKE AND RIDER
CARPOOL THEY WILL THEY DIDN'T
SPEND MONEY LOCALLY WE ARE
CREATING MORE WALKABLE BIKEABLE
PLATE BILL IF THEY DON'T
REQUIRE YOU TO OWN A CAR. WELL
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED HOUSING
FOR GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS TEACHERS TO BE EMPLOYED
IN COLLEGE GUYS. TO COME HOME
TO LASTLY AT THE STATE WE ARE
ACTIVELY EMBRACING ADVANCING
IDEAS AND PROJECTS THAT PROMOTE
THE CONCEPT OF FREE RANGE
PEOPLE. WE HAD ADVOCATED FOR
BUILDING AND PLANNING THAT
CONSIDERS FUTURE GENERATIONS AS
ALL CURRENT RESIDENTS THAT
DON'T OWN CARS. AND VANS THE
MOBILITY OPTIONS REFLECTS WHAT
WE ARE TEACHING THE YOUTH IN
HE COMMUNITY AND OUR COMMUNITY
THROUGH SAFE ROUTES TO SCHOOL.
AT FORTINO ONE SUPPORTS THE
VISION OF A HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
AND ENHANCES CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND LIVABILITY THANK
YOU AND A CONCLUSION. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU AND- I SHOULD
MENTION TO THEM. THE LEAD WAY
THIS WILL GO TO SUCK IN A
MOMENT- THAT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS- IT IS BEEN CUSTOMARY
IT HAS BEEN CUSTOMARY FOR
COMMITTEE CHAIRS THE INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. A
SOLD TODAY EACH SIDE WOULD
PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF TIME.
FOR THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. WE WILL
PERMIT EACH SIDE TO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES TO SPEAK. MAXIMUM FOR
UP TO TWO MINUTES EACH TOTAL-
THERE'S- TYPICALLY NO TIME
SHARING AS WELL AS PEOPLE TRY
TO KEEP TO THOSE. LIMITS ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY- WILL
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. ON
THE MEASURE. AND I'M GONNA ASK.
THAT WE LIMIT. TOTAL TESTIMONY.
BY TOTAL TESTIMONY POSITION
TESTIMONY SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. ONCE WE GET PAST
LEAD WITNESSES. TO A MAXIMUM OF
TEN MINUTES. PER SIDE FOR
SUPPORT TWO MINUTES
PROPOSITION. AND THAT'S OVER
AND ABOVE THE LEAD WITNESSES
SOUL. A MINUTE K. IF. YOU'RE
THERE HI EUROPE NEXT. OKAY IF
IT CAN YOU LET SOMEONE KNOW I'M
ON I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE TO DO
WE HEAR YOU AND YOU CAN JUST GO
AHEAD AND PROCEED. GREAT THIS
IS AMIR KHAN. ON THE RIGHT
PRESIDENT WAS RELATED
CALIFORNIA BOARD MEMBER WITH
THE COUNCIL DENZEL BUILDERS ONE
OF THE BILL'S CO SPONSOR. I'VE
BEEN DEVELOPING AND BUILDING
AFFORDABLE MIXED INCOME HOUSING
TO LAST TWENTY FOUR YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO HELP
THEM FIND STRONG SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY FORTINO ONE. I'M ALSO
ONE OF THE BILLS- MONSTERS.
PARKING REQUIREMENTS OR PERHAPS
THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
DRIVERS HELPING CALL TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA EXCEPT THE PARKING
REQUIREMENTS MAKES NEW
DEVELOPMENTS. IN PEOPLE LEAVING
THOUSANDS OF POTENTIAL HEALTH
AND- BACON UNDER UTILIZED. BY
ELIMINATING MINIMUM PARKING
REQUIREMENTS IN TRANSIT RICH
AREAS IN ALLOWING DEVELOPERS
FLEXIBILITY TO RIGHT. FOR
PARKING ILLEGALLY AT FOURTEEN
NO ONE WILL CUT THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS THE CALL FOR NEW
HOUSING. BUT WE'RE HELPING
CONSERVE RESIDENT YOU DON'T OWN
CARS. UNLOCK NEW POTENTIAL FOR
CALIFORNIA TAKEN UNDER UTILIZED
LAND SUPPLY. AND IN ADDITION
OUR RESEARCH SO THAT EIGHTY
FOURTEEN NO ONE WILL ACTUALLY
PROVE. THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
CALIFORNIA SINCE THE PHONE CALL
AND INCLUSIONARY HOUSING
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT YET THE FIRM
IN LOS ANGELES. THE PROVIDE
THE- FLEXIBILITY TO DEVELOPERS
THE BOUNTY ADDITIONAL DENSITY
AND PARKING NEEDS ALLOWING MORE
DEAL. WELL THE JURY PLACE IF
THEY WANT TO HELPING. THE
COMMUNITY HERE TRANSIT. AND
DEVELOPERS WILL CONTINUE TO
BUILD FOR THE MARKET AND- THE
MARKET STILL WANT PARKING
RECENT SURVEYS OF LAPD PARKING
SO THAT DEVELOPERS CHOSE. TO
MAX OUT DENSITY INCENTIVES AND
PROVIDE. EVEN MORE PARKING THAN
THE PROGRAM REQUIRED- AT
FOURTEEN NO ONE WILL PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY TO DEVELOPERS TO
SERVE A WIDER RANGE OF HEALTHY
TYPE. WILL ALSO HELP. LIKE
RESTAURANT THE TRANSVERSE
LOCATIONS. ET FORTINO ONE OF
THE SIMPLEST MOS DIRECT ACTION
THAT THEY CAN TAKE TODAY TO
TURN. BACK THE- CLOCK ON
CLIMATE CHANGE SUPPORT INFILL
HOUSING AND SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE. VOTE AND WE REALLY
THANK THE OFFICE FOR HER
CONTINUED. INCREDIBLE
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY THAT
CONCLUDES LEAD SUPPORT.
TESTIMONY I'M GOING TO ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF A SYMBOL FORTINO
ONE. THE SCENE KNOWN COME- ALL
ADD IF THERE'S ANY ONE ROOM
TWELVE WHICH IS SPEAK AND- OF
THIS BILL SEEN ONE THERE TO
TEST. WHO TO THE TWO. LINE NASA
MODERATE TO POLICE UP IN
SUPPORT THIS IS ON A BEFORE.
ONE IN A PLEASE US KNOW HOW.
YOU HAVE IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY WE WOULD LIKE TO STAY
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A. B. FOURTEEN
ONE. EXPRESSED FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN USING YOUR PHONE PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE AND THEN THE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MURDER YOU
MAY PROCEED. LOCAL FIRST LINE.
EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE RED HAWK
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO MAYOR
TODD GLORIA AND THE CITY
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. NEXT IS
LINE. EIGHTY THREE. DAVID
WATSON ON BEHALF OF NON Q. U.
B. STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF BABY
FORTINO ONE. FORTY NINE.
AFTERNOON CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ACTUALLY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS AND STRONG
SUPPORT IF A ND ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE OR THE NEIGHBORS
PEOPLE FOR HELPING ORANGE
COUNTY STREETS FOR PEOPLE ABOUT
THE NBA AND THE NBA ACTION
THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY THREE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS LAUREN TABLE
AND PEER REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. NINETY EIGHT.
TRUCKER DAISY MEMBERS ALEX FOR
THE STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IMPORT IF. NINE
EIGHTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON OUR
MEMBERS ARE LUIS MARIN HOW
FORTY YOU'D BE HERE THEY'VE
VERY PRIVATE UNDER THE BILL AND
INSTRUCT FOR. ONE OH ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUST AN ERROR
WITH THE SOLE COMBAT LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE
OH THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE NIGHT
AND THAT MIGHT HELP BUT LOOK AT
THEIR CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
GREENBELT ALLIANCE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION AND KOBE
AREA PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION ALLEGED
THAT PRODUCT CODE FINDER
DEVELOP ALL CALLING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE OH SEVEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB NAYLOR
REPRESENTING FEELS DEAD AND
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY. FORTINO ONE THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME
IS STEVE MILLER CALLING I
REPRESENT SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
OR ESSENCE BMB AND ABUNDANT
HOUSING LA AND YOU'RE IN STRONG
PART OF AB FORTINO ONE THANK
YOU. FIND ONE HUNDRED. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN NUMBERS TO
KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE OLD.
FIVE HI MY NAME IS PUBLIC MORE
I'M A RENTER AND SUPPORTER OF
CALIFORNIAN B. AND ALSO A
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL. FIND.
ONE OH EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEERING MEMBERS KIMBERLY DOWN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINETY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS JORDAN GRIMES ON BEHALF
OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN SENATE DISTRICT
THIRTEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FORTINO ONE. EIGHTY
SEVEN. HI THERE THIS IS OUR OWN
HARMONY IN SAN BRUNO JUST SOUTH
OF US ARE ARE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF AN INTERNAL AFFAIR EVERYONE
IN SUPPORT. ONE OH NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THEY'RE A LITTLE WITH
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ARSENAL BOSS I'M
CALLING FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA FOLLOWING AND
SUPPORT OF BABY FORTINO ONE
THANK YOU. NINETY THREE.
AFTERNOON THIS IS CHRIS
JEFFRIES AND THE MOTHER OF
THREE IN A SINGLE FAMILY HOME
OWNER IN SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY
AND OUR FAMILY TO STRONG
SUPPORT. NINETY SIX. BY HIS AXE
YOU'VE BEEN CALLING FROM SAN
FRANCISCO WITH URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINETY SEVEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DUNCAN
MCFETRIDGE REPRESENTING
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE OH SIX. MAC
ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF
ENTERTAINING IN BE IN SUPPORT.
NINETY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
BECAUSE WAS MINE IN NORFOLK
COUNTY WITH GENERATIONS HOUSING
CALLING SHOTS FOR. SIXTY FIVE.
NINE SIX FIVE YOUR TELEPHONE
MAYBE ON NEW. NEXUS LINE ONE
FOURTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON WITH A
POP UP ON THE BELT ON BEHALF OF
THE ENDOCRINE BMB IMPORT. ONE
ELEVEN. HI THIS IS SID COMPORT
WITH EACH STATE- IF THEY ENVY
IN CHUNKS THANK YOU. SEVENTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHERRY
MEMBERS ACTUALLY OUR ON BEHALF
OF THE MONTEREY BAY ECONOMIC
PARTNERSHIP REPRESENTING OVER
EIGHTY PUBLIC PRIVATE AND CIVIC
AND EVEN THE MODERATE SANTA
CRUZ AND SAN BENITO COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FOURTEEN OH ONE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. ONE SIXTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS HENRY
HOOKER CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CRUZ SENIORS FOR HOUSING
STRONG SUPPORT AT FORTINO ONE.
NINETY ONE. MATTHEW LEWIS
CALLING FROM SEPARATELY NOW
COALITION OF HOMEOWNERS AND
RENTERS IN BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCTIONS FOR. EIGHTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE NUMBERS
HIS FATHER CROP AND CALLING ON
BEHALF OF STANFORD FIFTY M. B.
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTEEN. THAT AFTERNOON
CARE MEMBERS LESLIE VASQUEZ
HERE WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
AT FORTINO ONE THANK YOU. ONE
EIGHTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MARKERS OF ARCTIC HERE CALLING
FROM ALAMEDA NASTY NINE- IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE ONE
TWENTY. BUY THE BOOK OUT THAT
WE WOULD NEVER LEAVE SANTA CRUZ
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
MAYBE FOURTEEN OH ONE. THANK
YOU NO FURTHER LINES IN QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT AT THIS TIME- THANK
YOU MODERATOR- WE'LL GO OVER TO
THE OPPOSITION SIDE NOW- LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ARE LISTED
AS CYNTHIA CASTIEL BEEN MUDDIED
MONTY- IS AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY
THIS TIME. YEAH I'M HERE HELLO
GREAT PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING OR AFTERNOON SHARE
NUMBERS THE BIGGEST DEAL WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED YOU AB
FOURTEEN ZERO ONE. WESTERN
CENTER WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREES
AND SUPPORTS THE OFFICE
INTENDED GOAL TO REMOVE
EXCESSIVE PARKINGREQUIREMENTS
AND ENCOURAGE HEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES LAST JULY AND
HUNGRY HOW CAPTIVATING CARD
UNFORTUNATELY AT FOURTEEN NO
ONE CURRENTLY DOES NOT STRIKE
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN A
POLICY OBJECTIVE AND I THINK
EQUALLY CRITICAL CALL. CREEPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
SUPPORTING LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THE QUESTION IS NOT
WHETHER W SHOULD ELIMINATE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS WE BELIEVE
WE SHOULD THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE ELIMINATION OF
PARKING REQUIREMENTS SHOULD BE
DONE IN COORDINATION WITH MIXED
INCOME AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
THAT THAT. FRAMEWORK OR
DEALINGS FOR LESS THAN THREE
THOUSAND ADS EIGHTY FORTY ONE
IS A CURRENT FORM OR MORE
SIMPLY IT'S A QUESTION OF
pPARKING REQUIREMENTS THE
PORTEND INCLUSIONARY
DEVELOPMENT OR LESS LESS THAN
EXCLUSIONARY DEVELOPMENT. I
THINK PARKING REDUCTIONS WITH
THE DENSITY BONUS FRAMEWORK
WILL ALLOW THE STATE TO CAPTURE
THE VALUE OF ANY BENEFIT
CONVEYED YOU THAT'S PRETTY
AFFORDABLE UNITS AND ACHIEVE
MORE DANCING YOUR TRANSIT
MEANING MORE HOUSING UNITS
ACROSS. WE KNOW THAT LOW INCOME
PEOPLE WHO LIVE NEAR TRANSIT
UTILIZE THAT TRANSIT FAR HIGHER
RATES AND HIGHER INCOME PEOPLE
WHO LIVE NEAR TRANSIT MAXIMIZE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT WE
SHOULD ALL WHO DRIVE TO
MAXIMIZE THE PORTABLE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES NEAR TRANSIT FOR
THE COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT.
IN ADDITION THE CLINICAL
REQUIRED REPLACEMENT OF ANY.
TOMATO PORTABLE ARIGHT HE TOLD.
THE REMOVING TO DO IT I THINK I
TRACK. AND FURTHER IMPACT ON
DECREASING THE SUPPLY. OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TRANSIT.
MAINTAINING THE REPLACE
BENEFITS CRITICAL AND BE GOOD
FOR THE PREFERRED QUALITY. IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE OFFICE
WITH HIM DRINKING. BY WHICH THE
CAN CREATE THE PART OF THE-
THEY WOULD. OR WHERE THE
PROJECT INCLUDES YOU KNOW.
GIVEN OUR HOUSING CRISIS WE
CANNOT AFFORD TO FOREGO ANY
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING NEW
PROJECTS FOR ABOUT HOW THE
FRAMEWORK WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
MAKE ANY AFFORDABILITY ON THE
TABLE WE SHOULD USE THE QUALITY
OPTION I REVIEWED THE PARKING
AND INCREASE THE PORTABILITY
TOGETHER. THIS IS THE BEST
APPROACH TO MAXIMIZING THE KIND
OF BENEFITS OF THAT BATTLE
EQUITABLE HOUSING POLICY IS THE
KIND OF QUALITY WE CAN CONFIRM
THE NUMBER FREEMAN OR STAFF AS.
WELL AS THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OF MUDDY
MONCHI APPEAR AVAILABLE YOU MAY
TESTIFY AT THIS TIME. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IT MIGHT BE MY G. AND I'M
WITHIN OUR CITY LAW CENTER IN
THE ALLIANCE FOR COMMUNITY
TRYING TO LOS ANGELES WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED AT FOURTEEN OH ONE. I
DON'T ENVISION DEDICATED TO
ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS AND IMPROVING
PUBLIC TRANSIT IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WE URGE YOU TO FOCUS ON
REDUCING PARKING REQUIREMENTS
AS PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH THAT INSURANCE PLAN
USE TRANSPORTATION. ALL THE
WORK IN TANDEM TO BENEFIT NOT
HARM MARK LIKE UNITY WE SUPPORT
INTO THIS BILL TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF LAND DEDICATED TO
CARS AND PARKING. ARE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF LA COUNTY COURT
TRANSIT RIDERS WITH BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE AND WE KNOW THAT
ONE OF THE MOST CRITICAL
STRATEGIES TO INCREASE THE
REGION TRYING TO USE HIS
MAXIMIZING EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESERVE AND PRETTY. WILD THING
INSTEAD LIKE BOEING CONTENT-
TRANSIT RECOUPING CORE LOWER
CONSTRUCTION COSTS DON'T
AUTOMATICALLY THINK THAT A
MEDICALLY TRICKLE DOWN TO RENT.
A PORTABLE TEND TO ACTUALLY
DEPEND ON TRAFFIC POPULATION IN
LA- WITH THE MEDIAN INCOME OF
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR IN ITS CURRENT FORM EIGHTY
FORTINO ONE DOES NOT CONTAIN
ANY PLAN FOR PORTABLE HOUSING
PRODUCTION OPERATIONS MADE
SENSE FIGHTING WITH THE
PROGRAM. WE BELIEVE LIMITING
PARKING PERMITS WILL GO HAND IN
HAND CREATING AND PRESERVING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING VALLEY
TRANSIT ORIENTED COMMUNITIES
PROGRAM CAN ACTUALLY TRAVEL
COMMUNITY DRIEN HOUSING
PROGRAM TO REDUCE PARKING
PERMIT. THE GREAT THOUSANDS OF
UNITS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO
ARE YOU GUYS BUILD BACK IN A
FEW OF THE PROGRAM WE JUST
RELEASED AN ALBUM. WE HOPE TO
WORK WITH YOUR OFFICE TO REDUCE
PARKING PERMITS WHILE PLANNING
FOR THAT OR HOW TO GET IT
NEEDED TO ADDRESS OUR
PORTABILITY HOW CAN. AN ALMOST
AS PRICES WE ARE DETERMINED AT
FOURTEEN WANT TO UTILIZE THE
VALUE PRACTICAL FRAMEWORK.
CAPITAL CONTROL WAKE UP
ACTUALLY ABLE TO CREATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SPECIFICALLY
YOUR QUESTION UNDERTAKING
FORTINO ONE THAT LIMITING
PARKING MINIMUMS. PRESIDENT OF
OUR DEVELOPMENT NEAR TRANSIT
ONLY ONE DEVELOPER YOU LIE
DETECTOR THE BONUS BAR WHERE
THE PROPOSED RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING WILL BE MARKED UP OR
HOW THE- CALIFORNIA ENERGY BOTH
NECESSARY KIND OF QUALITY AND
EQUITABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
IS STILL CONSIDERED. TO BE
THIRD OF MANY TRANSIT RIDERS
AND MAYBE THE COLOR IN CHRIST
WHICH ACTED HELPING QUITE A
COUPLE OF EVIL WITH OVER YET
PATHETIC RELATED ECONOMIC
SHUTDOWN HAS. FURTHER
STRATIFIED OUR COUNTY TO GO.
QUARTERLY HOUSE INTEL CORE LEFT
YOUR. THIS BILL OF SO- YOU MAY
PROCEED. A SCENE NONE- WE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM. FOR A ONE TWELVE
AND ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY THERE IS NOT
WE'LL GO BACK THE MODERATOR
ASKED MODERATOR QUEUE UP ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AB
FORTINO ONE AT THIS TIME AND-
THEN AGAIN WE'D APPRECIATE
KNOWING THE NUMBER. CERTAINLY
IF YOU LIKE TO STATE OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
ELEVEN LINES IN Q. LOCAL FIRST
CLIMB. SIXTY FIVE. SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I ACTUALLY
MET WITH MEANT TO BE ON THE
OTHER THING IS THAT TO SUPPORT
THE BILL- I FELT LIKE I WAS
MENTIONING MY NAME IT COULD BE
A NIGHTMARE. APOLOGIZE. LINE
EIGHTY SIX. BY BEING BROKEN
SENSOR PARKSIDE DISTRICT SAN
FRANCISCO IN OPPOSITION. FIFTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON JACQUELINE
AMERICAN HELPING CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOUR POINT
ZERO ONE THANK YOU. SEVENTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON YELLOW OR
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
WORLD LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION THE PUBLIC INTEREST
LAW PROJECT POLICY LINK
LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMUNITIES
FOR A BETTER ENVIRONMENT PUBLIC
COUNCIL AND THE COALITION FOR
ECONOMIC SURVIVAL ALL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SURE MEMBERS ON THIS PROMISE ON
BEHALF OF PUBLIC ADVOCATE WE
ARE ALSO OPPOSE THE MOST
AMENDED ON MAYBE FORTINO ONE OF
THE REASONS FOR THE REASONS
STATED BY THE SPEAKERS THANK
YOU. EIGHTY ONE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON RYAN LEE
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE ARE ALSO
IN OPPOSITION TO FORTUNE ONE
THANK YOU. SEVENTY TWO. HELLO
ANASTACIO ANNAPOLIS A MEMBER OF
ST FRANCISCO TENANTS UNION IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN OH
ONE THANK YOU. SIXTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
JAKE WHITAKER WITH THE RENT A
PUBLIC POLICY GROUP
REPRESENTING THE CITIES OF
FOSTER CITY CARLSBAD AND CORONA
IN OPPOSITION OF A. B. FORTINO
ONE THANK YOU. ONE TWELVE I
RECALL WITH LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OPPOSE FORTINO ONE. ONE
THIRTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS THIS IS JASMINE JOHNSON
ON BEHALF OF PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES IN OPPOSITION TO
FOURTEEN OH ONE THANK YOU. ONE
TWENTY FOUR. MY NAME IS FARMERS
ARE GREEK- WITH TACTILE WAY
OPPOSE AB FORTINO ONE UNLESS
AMENDED TO PREVENT MANDELIT
FROM PRICING OUT NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK YOU.
NO FURTHER LINES IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL COME
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NOW UNNECESSARY YOUR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR ANYONE
WANTS TO BE RECOGNIZED
GENERALLY- WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR SKINNER AND THEN
SENATOR CAFIERO. BY YOU- CHAIR.
I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- HEY
YOU KNOW THESE DEBATES. WE'RE
FACED IT CONTINUOUSLY WITH AND
SOME LEVEL OF THE OPPOSITION IS
OPPOSING BECAUSE THEY USE THE
PARKING REQUIREMENT TO TRY TO-
EXTRACTED THE BENEFITS. BUT I
FEEL AT THIS POINT IN TIME THE
COST OF REQUIRING PARKING
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT
JUSTIFIES THE MIND TO RESERVE-
ARE IT'S SO HARD IT IS SO
EXPENSIVE NOW TO CONSTRUCT
HOUSING THAT WE WOULD ADD THAT
REQUIREMENT AND ADD THAT COST
IN TIMES WHERE IT'S NOT
NECESSARY AND THAT WE WOULD
ALLOW PARKING TO BECOME. MORE
IMPORTANT IN HOUSING WHEN WE
ARE IN THE TYPE OF CRISIS THAT
WE'RE IN KIND OF FORCED ME
RIGHT NOW IN OAKLAND WHICH IS
IN MY DISTRICT THERE IS A LOW
INCOME HOUSING PROJECT. THAT
HAS A NUMBER OF UNITS THAT ARE
SPECIFIC FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE AT
BEEN EXPERIENCING HOMELESS THAT
IS BEING. HELD BACK BY THE
PARKING MANDATES AND- MOST OF
THE UNITS ARE WOULD BE FOR
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T AFFORD CARS IN
THE FIRST PLACE- ANYWAY SO I AM
VERY STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I'M HAPPY TO MOVE IT. OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER COPIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR SHE TOOK
THE TIME TO HAVE A FAIRLY
LENGTHY CONVERSATION WITH ME
ABOUT THE BILL- AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO THROUGH THE
DETAILS I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY- BUT I BUT
HERE'S HERE'S MY CONCERN IS
THAT- THE ANALYSIS WHICH IS
REALLY WELL DONE. GIVES EXAMPLE
AFTER EXAMPLE. EVERY EXAMPLE OF
WHICH IS A HEAVILY URBANIZED
AREA. TALK ABOUT SAN FRANCISCO
TALK ABOUT SAN DIEGO- TALK
ABOUT LOS ANGELES. AND MY
CONCERN REPRESENTING A- IT
WOULD BE A VERY RURAL. PART OF
THE STATE IS THAT- OUR ISSUES
IS THAT WE DESPERATELY WANT THE
EXTENSION OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I'VE LONG
THOUGHT THAT OUR OVER RELIANCE
ON ACHIEVING CLIMATE CHANGE BY
MOVING FROM- FOSSIL FUEL VIA
VEHICLES TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES
MISSES THE POINT WHICH IS THAT
WHAT WE REALLY WANT IS PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR VEHICLES PERIOD.
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS BY EXTENDING OUR PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS IN THE
PARTS OF THE STATE WHERE PEOPLE
REALLY WOULD GET OUT OF THEIR
VEHICLE AND IF THERE WAS AN
OPTION AND SO I WANT I THE PART
OF THE CHALLENGE THAT I HAVE
DESPITE THE FACT AND I AND I
WANT TO. RECOGNIZE THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE THAT ARE
GOOD FOR RURAL COMMUNITIES THIS
FRANKLY IS NOT GOING TO APPLY.
EXCEPT FOR IN VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES AROUND TO TRAIN
STATIONS IN MY DISTRICT. BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT IT SETS UP. IT
SETS THE TRAIN IN MOTION IF YOU
WILL- I GET CONCERNED ABOUT
EXTENDING IT BEYOND THAT
BECAUSE- IN MY COMMUNITIES THEY
DESPERATELY WANT HOUSING. AND
BUT THEY ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT IT FITS IN
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY AND THAT
THERE IS THERE ARE ENOUGH
PARKING SPACES- IT TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT THE
WORDS IN MY IN MY REGION PEOPLE
ARE NOT CONCERNED. ABOUT
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF PARKING
SPACES THEY WANT MORE BECAUSE
OF SUCH OF THE SOME OF THIS
OVER CROWDED. HOUSING SITUATION
SO IN ANY CASE- I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR I THINK SHE'S DONE A
GOOD JOB WITH THIS- I WOULD
HAVE FELT BETTER IF IT'D JUST
EXCLUDED RURAL AREAS COMPLETELY
pAT- WHAT THIS IS DONE FOR THE
URBAN AREAS BUT- BUT GIVEN THE
LIMITATIONS. LIMITATIONS ON
EXACTLY WHERE IT APPLIES I'M
I'M PREPARED TO SUPPORT TODAY
AND RESERVE JUDGMENT ON. WHEN
IT HITS THE FLOOR IF IT GETS
THAT FAR. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR OTHER. COMMENTS
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS AN
ARRANGEMENT. THANK YOU- AND I
WANT TO THANK THE ESTIMATE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I SERVED
ON A STOCKTON IN STOCKTON CITY
COUNCIL AND IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX TO TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE
AND I REPRESENT THE MIDTOWN
DOWNTOWN AREA OF STOCKTON AND
IT WAS SO FRUSTRATING TRYING TO
GET HOUSING I DEVELOPED IN OUR
DOWNTOWN AND IN IN THE
SURROUNDING AREAS AND
OFTENTIMES HELD UP BECAUSE OF
PARKING ISSUES- BUT I ALSO I
ALSO WANT TO GIVE CREDENCE TO
WHAT THE SENATOR FROM SALINAS
IS SAYING IS THAT THE ELECTRIC
CARS ARE NOT THE ANSWER BUT WE
NEED BETTER PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND I ONLY.
ASPIRE TO THE DAY. WHEN WE'LL
GET OUR VALLEY LINK TRAIN
CONNECTED AND MAYBE BE ABLE TO
TELL YOU SOMETHING LIKE THIS
MORE BUT- I SUPPORT THIS BILL I
DO NOT THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE.
ELEVATING PARKING OVER HOUSING-
AND AT THE SAME TIME IN AREAS
THAT HAVE LESS. A PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION PEOPLE GONNA
HAVE MORE VEHICLES BUT
OFTENTIMES IT DOESN'T APPLY TO
THE AREAS WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO. DEVELOP THIS KIND OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO. I AM
ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING FOR IT WHEN THE TIME
COMES. THE SENATOR OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO BE RECOGNIZED ON THE
COMMITTEE. OF C. NONE- IT'LL BE
JUST AS- MAKE A QUICK COMMENT
BEFORE- POLONY OFTEN UP TO
CLOTHES- AN ASSOCIATE WITH A
SOCIALLY MY COMMENTS JUST
GENERALLY- WITH THOSE OF
SENATOR CAFIERO- IN EIGHTY
EIGHT FIFTY IN IN IN MOST
PARTS- I DO WANT TO- INDICATOR
ALSO HAD- HERO A GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
AND EXPECT TO HAVE ANOTHER ONE
AT SOME POINT- BUT I WILL
SUPPORT THE BUILDING OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY I DO THINK MORE
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE- NOT ONLY
ALONG THE LINES OF- SENATOR.
KABIR WAS COMMENTS IN TERMS OF
NON URBAN AREAS PUT IT IN A
HIGHLY IMPACTED IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN IN URBAN
AREAS LIKE WE HAVE ANY
SENTENCING AROUND OUR MAJOR
TRANSIT STOPS SO I'D I DON'T
THINK THE BILL IS FAR OFF IN
THAT REGARD BUT I WOULD HOPE-
THEY'LL BE SOME CONTINUED-
THOUGHTFULNESS IN TERMS OF HOW
TO PROCEED ON THAT SAID- I JUST
WANNA GET MY COMMENTS ON THE
RECORD- I THANK YOU FOR- ONLY
WORK ON THE BILL THE SOME
REMEMBER IN A GIVEN OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
AND THANKS EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
REALLY WELL THOUGHT OUT THEM
COMMENTS- I TOTALLY AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID TODAY
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
IN OUR RURAL AREAS WHEN IT
COMES TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND PROBLEMS WITH
PARKING THE SOLUTION IS BETTER
TRANSIT IT'S US INVESTING AS A
STATE IN TRANSIT AND DE
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE FOR PEOPLE
TAKE UP MUCH NEEDED LAND FOR
PARKS NEEDED LAND FOR
BUSINESSES CERTAINLY NEEDED
LAND FOR HOUSING. SO CONTINUING
MISSILE CONTINUING A SYSTEM
THAT WE KNOW IS LEAD TO BAD
MOBILITY TRAFFIC CONGESTION AIR
POLLUTION AND EVERYTHING ELSE
IS NOT THE ANSWER THE ANSWER IS
TO SHIFT TO OUR FOCUS ON A
TRANSIT AND. THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IT I'M CERTAINLY
COMMITTED A AS IS PRESS FOR
CHARACTER WITH YOU ALL OF THE
ON THAT THAT'S WHY I'M THERE.
THAT'S THE GOAL ARE YOU SAY IN
TERMS OF THE OFFICE. I UNDER
THE CONCERN ABOUT WHAT THIS
WILL DO TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BUT WE HAVE DATA WE HAVE ACTUAL
DATA AND ACTUAL LIVING PROOF.
FIRST OF ALL WHEN SAN DIEGO DID
EXACTLY THAT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION WENT UP FOUR
TIMES. AND THE REASON IS
BECAUSE WELL THEY MENTION VALUE
CAPTURE THERE IS NO VALUE
CAPTURE REDUCING PARKING THAT'S
WHY MERCURY DEVELOPERS ARE
STILL BUILDING WITH THE SAME
AMOUNT OF PARKING EVEN IF THEY
DON'T HAVE TO. WHAT IT DOES DO
IS ALLOW PEOPLE WHO ARE WANTING
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR
FOR MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING TO
REDUCE THEIR COSTS AND PASS
THAT ALONG TO PEOPLE. THAT'S
WHAT IT ACTUALLY ALLOWS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO OTHER
CREATIVE THINGS LIKE TANDEM
PARKING. OFFERING SOME UNITS
WITH LESS PARKING. AND SO WE
KNOW THAT JUST FROM DATA THAT
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO HAVE THE
TYPE OF IMPACT THAT THEY'RE
AFRAID THAT WE'LL HAVE.
SECONDLY THEY SAID SOMETHING
VERY INTERESTING THAT THEY
DON'T LIKE ALL THE PARKING
BECAUSE OF THE AIR QUALITY
ISSUES THE POLLUTION PROBLEMS
THE CONGESTION PROBLEMS. TO
SORT OF MAINTAIN THAT IN ORDER
TO BARGAIN IT BACK TO TRY TO
BARGAIN A BATH. REALLY JUST
SEEMS LIKE THE WRONG TOPIC YOU
KNOW SOMETHING'S CAUSING HARM
DON'T USE THAT AS YOUR
BARGAININ CHIP- IT'S JUST THE
WRONG WAY TO DO IT. REMOVE THAT
INSTANT THAT DISINCENTIVE.
CREATING POLLUTION EVERY
REQUIREMENTS IF YOU LIKE BUT
LET'S CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO
BRING DOWN THE COST OF BUILDING
HOUSING THAT'S WHAT THIS WILL
DO AND I REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
ICE OF THE ITEMS TODAY THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. AND JUST
WANT CONFIRM. SKINNER HAS MADE
THE MOTION. TO MOVE THE BILL.
WITHOUT US CONSULTANT CULTURAL
PLEASE. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTINO ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CENTER COURTESY HI CORTESE I'D
BATES. BATES NOAH CABRERA
CABRERA HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN FIVE
MAGUIRE BUT SHOW A BOOK THE
TROUBLED NOW SKINNER. SKINNER
HI AMBER. WHAT KASKY HOTEL SKI
I. FIVE TO TWO. BUT DUE TO
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR THE
OPS MEMBERS THANK YOU. BUT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
ITEM INFO ORDER IN THAT WOULD
BE EIGHTY THREE SIXTY TWO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
WELCOME AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND SENATORS
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE
PRESENTING HERE IN THIS
BEAUTIFUL CHAMBER I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A B. THREE SIX TWO MY
CHILD CARE OPERATORS
ACCOUNTABILITY BILL. I WANT TO
START OFF BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH MY
STAFF ON THE BILL. AB THREE SIX
TWO ENSURES MINIMUM HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS ARE FOLLOWED
BY SHELTER OPERATORS AND THAT
ALL SHELTER RESIDENTS ARE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT. A YEAR LONG.
INVESTIGATION BY THE AMERICANS
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOUND
SEVERE DEFICITS AMONG VARIOUS
EMERGENCY SHELTERS IN ORANGE
COUNTY. WITH REPORTS OF ALLEGED
SEXUAL ABUSE OVERCROWDING
UNHEALTHY CONDITIONS AND GO
ACTIVE RESIDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND MENTAL
ILLNESSES. THIS INVESTIGATION
ALSO HIGHLIGHTED THE UNSANITARY
CONDITIONS IN THE SHELTERS
INCLUDING WIDESPREAD ROAD AND
BEDBUG INFESTATIONS EXTREME
TEMPERATURES BROKEN SHOWERS AND
TOILETS. THE NEED FOR
ENFORCEABLE AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY SANT STANDARDS FOR
HOMELESS SHELTERS IS URGENT.
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
VULNERABILITY OF HOMELESS
SHELTER RESIDENTS MANY OF WHOM
ARE OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS. EVEN
THOUGH HELP SHELTERS WERE NEVER
INTENDED TO SERVE AS A LONG
TERM HOUSING THE REALITY IS AND
TELL THE HOUSING CRISIS IS
ADDRESS MANY OF THE SHELTERS
WERE SET OR- WILL SERVE AS A
PRIMARY RESIDENCE FOR
UNSHELTERED CALIFORNIANS. AS
OUR STATE CONTINUES TO FACE A
GROWING HOMELESS CRISIS THIS
BILL IS THE FIRST STEP IN
CORRECTING SOME OF THE ISSUES
AT THE SHELTERS. WITH ME TODAY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS EVE GARO WITH. ACLU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I'M ASSUMING
MEMBER IN. WE WILL NOW GO TO-
GIRL YOUR LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I AM
A POLICY ANALYST WITH THE ACLU
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ONE
OF THE AUTHORS OF THE REPORT.
TO END THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA MUST
EXPAND ACCESS TO PERMANENT
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO ALL WHO NEED IT IN THE
MEANTIME WE MUST ENSURE THAT
HOMELESS SHELTERS WHICH ARE
OFTEN THE ONLY ALTERNATIVE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE DISPLACED FROM
THEIR HOUSE THESE ARE SAFE
PLACES TO LIVE. MY YEARLONG
INVESTIGATION OF SEVERAL
HOMELESS SHELTERS IN ORANGE
COUNTY FOUND THAT SHELTERS
INSTEAD OFTEN EXPOSED RESIDENTS
TO CONDITIONS IN FLAGRANT
DISREGARD OF THEIR HEALTH AND
WELL BEING ONE SHELTER I
INVESTIGATED WITHIN AN OPEN AIR
CONVERTED BUS TERMINAL PEOPLE
ARE SOMETIMES EXPOSED TO WIND
AND RAIN THERE WAS NO
TEMPERATURE CONTROL AND
RESIDENTS SUFFERED FROM
EXPOSURE TO EXTREME HEAT AND
COLD SHOWERS OFTEN RAN COLD
LEECH BLACKWATER AND WE'RE
SOMETIMES BROKEN FOR WEEKS.
WERE OFTEN BROKEN AN
OVERFLOWING WITH HUMAN WASTE
INFESTATIONS OF MAGGOT BERMAN
AND INFLEXIBLE COMMON MY
INVESTIGATION ALONG WITH OTHER
EXPOSES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
INDICATE THAT UNSAFE AND
UNSANITARY SHELTER CONDITIONS.
CAN AND DO HAPPEN EVERYWHERE.
WHAT OVERSIGHT IN FOURTH OF. TO
HELP IN SAFETY IS THE TO THESE
PROBLEMS. EXISTING LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE HOMELESS SHELTERS TO BE
INSPECTED ON A REGULAR BASIS
AND WE HAVE FOUND THAT
RESIDENTS OF A SHELTER ARE
UNLIKELY TO LODGE COMPLAINTS
DUE TO FEARS OF BEING AFFECTED
FROM THE SHELTER. IN
RETALIATION FOR REPORTING.
EIGHTY THREE SIXTY TWO WOULD
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO CONDUCT AT LEAST
ONE INSPECTION OF EACH HOMELESS
SHELTER IN ITS JURISDICTION PER
YEAR. AND RESPOND IN A TIMELY
MANNER TO LEGITIMATE COMPLAINT.
OWNERS OR OPERATORS THAT
REPEATEDLY VIOLATE EXISTING
STANDARDS MAY BE DEEMED
INELIGIBLE FOR STATE FUNDING
ADDITIONALLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT AN
ANNUAL REPORT. TO H. C. D.
IDENTIFYING VIOLATIONS OF THE
STATE HOUSING LAW WHICH MAY BE
USED TO BE A SHELTER OPERATOR
IN ELIGIBLE FOR STATE FUNDING.
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS DESERVE BETTER WITHOUT
I ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT. EIGHTY THREE SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU. IT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TOES- WE WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE. HERE IN THE
GALLERY WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY TWO.
IF SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD. I
SEE NONE- WE WILL LOOK GOOD TO
THE OVERFLOW ROOM TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THERE WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY ON THIS BILL SEEN
NONE. THE MODERATOR NOW SMARTER
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT
WITNESSES ON AB THREE SIXTY TWO
AND ONCE AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
KNOWING THE NUMBER IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. TO LEAVE THE PORT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE AT
THIS TIME AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO PLEASE. WE HAVE FOUR
LINES IN Q. FOUR GOAL FIRST
LINE FIFTY TWO. BUT AFTER THAT
WE HAVE A HEALTHY CALIFORNIAN
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THREE SIXTY
THANK YOU. ONE THIRTY.
RESEARCHER MEMBERS RAND MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION AND IT'S
HEALTHY HOUSING FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. SIXTY
FOUR. SHE TURNED THEM WITH MANY
ALEXANDER RODRIGUEZ BC YOU
CALIFORNIA ACTION INSTRUCTOR
FOR. LINE SEVENTY FOUR. HELLO
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
BRIAN CALLEY RHETORIC FOUNDING
MEMBER STRONGER WOMEN UNITED A
COALITION OF AN HOUSE FORMERLY
ON HOW AND HOW ALLIES WE
STRONGLY ENDORSE EIGHTY THREE
SIXTY TWO AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IPHONES THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES AND
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR- WE ALSO HAVE NEW
LEADOFF POSITION AGAIN A FIGHT
THIS TIME SO WE JUST ASK
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
WISHES TO TAKE AN OP AND A POST
POSITION ON THIS BILL. IF SO
PLEASE STEP FORWARD SEE NONE
WE'LL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM-
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO TESTIFY
I WILL COME BACK TO THE
MODERATOR NASA MODERATOR- TO
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON AB THREE SIXTY
TWO. TO STAY HERE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEY'RE ON YOUR TELEPHONE. YEN
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO USING
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. WE DO
HAVE ONE ONE LINE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. FINE ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY
I MADE A MISTAKE I'M NOT IN A
POSITION WHERE RIGHT MY MAN.
THANK YOU MODERATOR KNOWN ABOUT
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE IT.
WE'RE GOING TO COME BACK TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE NOW
FOR ANY OF COMMENT- THAT THEY'D
LIKE TO MAKE SOME ARRANGEMENTS.
THANK YOU M. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU A SEVEN
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THAT IS REALLY
INTERESTING YOU KNOW AS WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD UP OUR
SHELTER SYSTEM AND UNDERSTAND
HOW MANY AND HOUSE PEOPLE THAT
WE NEED TO GET IN SHELTERS. I
THINK IS THAT A DILEMMA WE FACE
SO AND I AND I'M WONDERING IN
IT WASN'T CLEAR TO ME IN THE IN
THE ANALYSIS IF WE DO FIND OUT
FIND SOMETHING BUT WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE LIVING SUBSTANDARD
BUT WE ALSO DON'T WANT THESE TO
CLOSE. SO IF THERE IF THERE IS
A VIOLATION NOTIFIED ENOUGH AND
IN ORDER TO- TO FIX IT. IS
THERE ANY I MEAN IS IT JUST
BASICALLY WITH UP WITH THE
FUNDS AT THE SHELTER ALREADY
HAS IS IT IS THE LOCAL.
JURISDICTION BUT THEY YOU KNOW
IF THEY WOULD BE AT ALL
RESPONSIBLE. AND THEN WHAT
HAPPENS IF THEY DO HAVE TO
ACTUALLY SHUT IT DOWN WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE FOLKS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN A SHELTER. OR WILL
THERE BE. APT TO COME ON GOING
RELATIONSHIP I GUESS BETWEEN
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION IN THAT.
AND THAT THE HOMELESS SHELTER.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION VERY
GOOD- I CERTAINLY. IS NOT
INTENDING WITH THIS BILL TO
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
OPERATE SHELTERS WERE MORE
EXPENSIVE. OUR INTENT IS TO.
MAKE SURE THAT MINIMUM
STANDARDS OR- AND AS FAR AS-
FIXING WHETHER IT BE TOILET-
SHELLED. SHOWERS THINGS LIKE
THAT THOSE ARE ALL UNDER THE
PROVIDERS UMBRELLA MEANING THEY
SHOULD ALREADY BE ADDRESSING
MAINTENANCE FOR THE SHELTERS AS
AN ONGOING. PROCESS HI AS
PEOPLE ARE BEING HOUSED THERE
BUT WE CERTAINLY WILL MAKE SURE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN. THOSE
THAT ARE LOOKING TO ADDRESS
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THOSE THAT
ARE PROVIDING THE SERVICE AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW I'VE WORKED IN
THIS SPACE THE LAST THING I
WANT TO DO IS MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
REALIZE. THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE HOMELESS THAT BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE IT DOES
NOT GIVE US THE- EXCUSE TO SAY
WELL WE DON'T REALLY NEED TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND I KNOW
THAT YOU AGREE WITH THAT I'VE
USE YOU WORK IN THE CITY THE
SPACE AS WELL. THANK YOU
ANYTHING ELSE IN REGARDS. NO I
JUST I JUST THINK THAT I AM
GLAD THIS FAMILY MEMBERS TAKING
ON THIS ON I KNOW SHE'S GOT A-
A REAL INTEREST IN THIS IN THIS
AREA AS AS AS WE ALL DO BUT
IT'S JUST YOU KNOW I THINK AS
WE AS WE CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH
OUR NEW REALITY ALL OF THESE
ISSUES WILL CONTINUE TO BE
REALLY INTERESTING AS WE GET
INTO THE NITTY GRITTY OF HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY. IN FORCE SOME OF
THE REGULATIONS THAT WE WANT TO
PUT FORWARD. WHEN WE'RE DEALING
WITH AN INCREDIBLY VULNERABLE
POPULATION AT THE SAME TIME.
AND A LACK OF. AVAILABLE PLACES
TO PUT PEOPLE. THANK YOU AND I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL THE PROPER
TIME. OKAY THANK SENATOR
EDMUND- ANY- ANYONE ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED. BUT SEE NONE- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER EIGHT
MEN IN THE SOME MEMBERS YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YOU MAY DO SO AT
THIS TIME. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE REALLY THANK YOU
AND THE LAST CONSOLE THE
CORPORAL PLEASE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE SIXTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ.
CORTEZ III BATES. COPYRIGHT
COPYRIGHT BY EGGMAN EGGMAN I AM
A CHOIR BUT SHOW A BOOK. NOT
VOTING SKINNER SKINNER BY
NUMBER. NUMBER HI WE CASKEY
WITH CASKEY HI. SIX ALL RIGHTS
RESERVED SIX FIVE VOTES- I
THINK THERE WAS BUT I'M SORRY
SIX ALL VOTES IN- WILL GO AND
PUT THE- ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SOME MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THAT NEXT BILL. IS EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY ONE THIS IS A MEMBERS
THINGS BILL- MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT CENTER SKINNER WILL BE
PRESENTING- IF THAT'S THE CASE
CENTER YOU MAY PRESENT FROM
YOUR DESK IF YOU WISH- I
UNDERSTAND THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON HAD A TIME CAN A
CONSTRAINT SO. I AM COMFORTABLE
ALLOWING HIM TO PRESENT. PRIOR
TO ME IF THAT IS OKAY WITH THE
CHAIR. BY THE A WEEKEND IF
THERE'S NO OBJECTION FROM THE
REST OF COMMITTEE WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND NOT TAKE- LET'S TAKE
THIS THE AUTHOR OUT OF ORDER.
IN THIS IS BUT ONE SHOULD
PLEASE STEP UP AND JUST
IDENTIFY YOURSELF IN THE BILL
THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING PLEASE
THANK YOU. TO REMEMBER TIM
GRAYSON- PRESENTING A B. SIX.
ZERO TWO. FOUR GREAT THANK YOU
FOR THAT IN THE UNIVERSITY
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THE
SUMMER THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO THE
SENATORS- SCANNER FOR
ACCOMMODATING- MY SPECIAL
REQUEST. AND GOOD AFTERNOON TO
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND ALL THE-
CENTERS COMMITTEE MEMBERS. A.
B. SIX ZERO TWO ESTABLISHES
TRANSPORTATION OR TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY STANDARDS
FOR THE NEXUS STUDIES THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PREPARE WHEN
IMPOSING DEVELOPMENT FEES OR
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES. THESE
INCLUDE REQUIREMENTS THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS STATE THEIR
EXISTING LEVELS OF SERVICE.
PROVIDED CAPITAL FACILITIES
PLAN FOR PROPOSED EXPENDITURES
AND COMPLY WITH PUBLIC NOTICE
AND OPENING THE OPEN MEETING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS BILL WILL
TIE FEES MORE CLOSELY TO THE
ACTUAL IMPACTS OF NEW
DEVELOPMENT BY REQUIRING THAT
FEES BE PROPORTIONAL TO THE
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF A PROPOSED
UNIT OR UNITS. AN ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT OF THIS POLICY IS THAT
DEVELOPERS WILL BE GIVEN AN
INCENTIVE TO SUB DIVIDE
PROJECTS INTO SMALLER MORE
NATURALLY AFFORDABLE UNITS. THE
BILL ALSO DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TO
DEVELOP A TEMPLATE FOR NEXUS
STUDIES THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS MAY CHOOSE TO
USE. THAT MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO THE WAY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS POSTER IMPACT
FEES ONLINE. TAKEN TOGETHER
THESE COMMON SENSE REFORMS WILL
PROVIDE CONSISTENCY CLARITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE WAY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DETERMINE
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES. HERE
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS BILL IN ADDRESSING OUR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS OR
TWO WITNESSES I. THREW THE
CHAIR WOULD HAVE SELF INTRODUCE.
YES SIR THANK YOU- THANK YOU
SOME EVER UNDERSTAND THE LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES OR- LOOSE
BRONTE AND- SO SON. MARTIN NOT-
MISTER MARATHI IF YOU WANT TO
PROCEED YOU MAY DO SO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WHO RESPONDED
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BE.
HERE THEY CUT UNDER THE BILL
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA BE IT THAT A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT MOVES THAT THEY ARE MUCH
FURTHER IN THE DIRECTION OF
MAKING SURE THE PUBLIC IS
COMPARABLE TO THE KEYS WE ARE
PAYING FOR HOUSING. ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO THINGS THAT
ARE ARE ARE NEEDED ARE FAIRLY
DECIDED ON BY TRAIN FOR OF
PUBLIC ART THAT. AND ARE
PROPORTIONAL THE ACTUAL IMPACT
OF THE HOUSE. THE TWO OF THE
TEACHERS THAT FAILED BUT I
THINK WE'RE MOST PASSIONATE
ABOUT. THAT AT THE RATE THAT
AND I DID THAT TOUCHED ON ARE
THE ARE THE PIECES OUT TRYING.
TO THE CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PLAN. THE BILL WOULD SAY THAT
HE'S IDENTIFIED. I THINK THE
NEXT BODY PART THAT. ONLY
SUPPORT OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE CAPITAL PLAN
BUT THE PUBLIC DOCUMENTS WILL
BE GOVERNMENTS WILL ADOPT. TO
REPUBLIC PROCESS IT SURE THAT
THE INVESTMENTS WE ARE MAKING
OUT WITH THE DOLLARS ARE
ACTUALLY SAYING THAT A PUBLIC
PROCESS HAS RESULTED IN THINGS
ARE IMPORTANT THAT THAT'S
CRITICAL MAKING SURE WE'RE NOT.
CHARGING THREE FEET PREVALENT.
I CAN'T WORK. CATCHY ABOUT THE
A PART OF THE BILL THAT WOULD
MAKE IT- THAT WOULD MAKE THESE.
ARSENAL DESPITE THE UNIT.
CURRENTLY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAY
ADOPT THESE IN ANY MANNER THEY
SEE FIT. GET IT AND SOME LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ADOPT THEM ON A PER
SQUARE FOOT BASIS COMING UP ON
A PER UNIT BASIS. OUR CONCERN
IS THAT HE THOUGHT THAT ON A
PER UNIT BASIS- INHERENTLY
FAVOR IN THE EYES LARGER UNIT-
WE CALIFORNIA SUCH A SHORTAGE-
NATURALLY PORTABLE. IT MIDDLE
CLASS HOUSING IT MAKES SENSE
THAT WE ARE. TOO LARGE TO BE AT
TO ENCOURAGE THAT WERE INVENTED
BY FAX OR DID YOU REALLY NOT
DISINFECTED BY SMALLER MORE
NATURALLY ORAL PRODUCTS- BACK I
THINK THE- I HEADED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE ASSISTANT. AND THING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
THANKS FOR WITH FIRST YOUR TOE
LIMITS- NEXT LEAD WITNESS IS SO
MONDAY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE DOESN'T MATTER NOT
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AND ITS
AFFILIATES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HOW TO CONFRONTING THIS
MANAGER. WHO AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS IN A HOUSING
CRISIS ALL ACROSS THE HOUSING
SPECTRUM FROM HOMELESSNESS
OWNERSHIP WOULD BE AN
INCREASING COST PRESSURES AND
WE STRIVE TO PROVIDE A DECENT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO OUR
RESIDENTS. AND ONE OF THE FEW
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP
HOUSING DEVELOPERS IN
CALIFORNIA HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
IS INCREASINGLY IMPACTED BY OUR
STATE HIGH HOUSING COSTS.
ESPECIALLY THE CONCEPT
INSTRUCTION BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
ENSURE OUR HOME DO NOT EXCEED
30% OF OUR OWNERS INCOME WE
COVER THAT GAP OF FUNDING IN
THE SHOULDER THE EVER
INCREASING. COST BURDEN LIKE
IMPACT FEES. EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
PROVIDE TRANSFER INTO AS WHAT
THE SPEAKER DIRECTLY CONNECTED
TO YOU BY CREATING CLEAR
GUIDELINES AN ACCOUNT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR NEXUS
STUDIES ENSURING THAT EITHER
PROPORTIONAL TO THE SQUARE BUT
AT THE UNIT. THIS ENCOURAGES
DEVELOPERS TO BUILD SMALLER
MORE NATURALLY AFFORDABLE
HOMES. ACCESSIBLE TO MORE
BUYERS HOPEFULLY INCREASING
CALIFORNIA'S EXTREMELY LOW RATE
OF HOMEOWNERSHIP. THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT FIRST STEP IN
CREATING MOREAFFORDABLE ENTRY
LEVEL HOUSING UNITS FOR
PURCHASE. CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GENERATIONAL
WEALTH AND STABILITY FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY
LEFT OUT IN THE REAL ESTATE
MARKET. WANT TO THANK YOU
FAMILY MEMBER FOR BEING A
LEADER ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. AND THE
DAUGHTERS ACTUALLY REQUEST AND
I DON'T THINK YOU'RE- OR DEGREE
TESTIMONY- WILL MOVE TO THE
GALLERY NASA THERE'S ANYONE. IN
THE GALLERY WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS ITEM EIGHTY
SIX OH TWO. A SINGLE STEP
FORWARD WE'LL CHECK YOUR FULL
ROOM. DOES NOT APPEAR TO BE
ANYONE THERE TO TESTIFY. LESS A
MODERATOR TO PLEASE QUEUE UP.
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO TAKE A
SUPPORT POSITION ON A. B. SIX
OH TWO AND AGAIN THIS IS FOR
NAME AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT
ONLY. SURE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
USING YOUR TELEPHONE. ONE MIN
ZERO PLEASE. WE HAVE EIGHT
LINES IN Q. WILL WE WILL CALL
FIRST CAROLINA NINETY EIGHT. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX TAURUS ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. I'M DAVID WHAT'S
IN THE NUMBER OF NON D. YOU'D
BE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY SIX AND
TWO. ONE FORTY ONE. RESEARCHER
BOB NAYLOR- FOR FUEL INSTEAD
AND COMPANY IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SIX OH TWO. ONE FORTY
FIVE. HI THIS IS CAROL KELLY
WOULD NEVER BE SANTA CRUZ
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
SIX OKAY. ONE FORTY SIX. HELLO
MY NAME IS OPERATE Q. LATE IN
BERKELEY AND I'M THANKFUL FOR
YOU. ONE FORTY. HI THIS IS OUR
OFFICE HARMONY IN SAN BRUNO
CALLING THE NUMBER TEN SPOT FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT. ONE THIRTY
THREE. LINE ONE THREE THREE ARE
YOU ON MUTE. I'M FROM THE-
FIGHTING A HUNDRED CHARACTERS I
DON'T THINK TRAVELER FROM LOS
ANGELES WE HAVE A STORY FROM
THE FRONT LINES AND HOLLYWOOD
FORWARD CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FORTY NINE.
AFTERNOON MANY MEMBERS-
TACKLING SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
UKRAINIAN B. AND ALLIGATOR FOR
EVERYONE AND- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. ONE
FORTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
HENRY HOOKER CALLING ON BEHALF
OF SANTA CRUZ DJEMBE EM SANTA
CRUZ SENIORS FOR HOUSING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINETY FIVE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THE CONSENSUS WAS MINUS ON THE
COUNTY ATTORNEY FROM HOUSING
TRANSPORT. BORN ON. THREE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE I
THOUGHT LOOK AT THEIR CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE THEORIES THE
KOBE AREA PLANNING URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION. AND THE
AT HOME AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
IDENTIFIED BUT WE WILL ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN THE
GALLERY WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. ON A. B. SIX OH TWO
SO PLEASE STEP FORWARD. I SEE
NONE WE'LL CHECK YOUR FULL
ROOM- THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO
TESTIFY. WE COME RIGHT BACK TO
THE MODERATOR AND MODERATOR-
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR QUEUING UP.
WITNESSES SYSTEM WERE
INTERESTED IN OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON THE B. SIX OH TWO.
THANK YOU THE STATE OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO USING YOUR PHONE
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO WE
DO HAVE ONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
IT'S LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARE NUMBERS THIS IS
CHRIS LEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND TODAY AS WELL ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALL WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON
EIGHTY SIX OH TWO. WE'VE GOT
TWO REMAINING ISSUES OUTLINED
IN OUR LETTER AND HOPE TO
RESOLVE THOSE IN APPROPRIATIONS
AND GET TO NEUTRAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NO FURTHER LINES AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR-
WILL LOOK NOW TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON THE BILL.
BUT SEEN SEE NO ONE WHO WISHES
TO BE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK ON
THE BILL WILL COME BACK TO THE
AUTHOR NOW C. AUTHOR IF YOU
LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY CLOSE THANK
YOU MR CHAIR WHEN CONSIDERING
LEGISLATION RELATED TO
DEVELOPMENT IMPACT FEES THE
PRIMARY CHALLENGE COMES IN
BALANCING TO LEGITIMATE POLICY
PRIORITIES PRESERVING THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THE FUND AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT NEW HOUSING
AND ENSURING THAT NEW HOMES AND
NEW HOMEOWNERS DO NOT BEAR A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THIS
COST. THIS BILL THROUGH ITS
COLLABORATIVE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE BETWEEN THESE GOALS
WILL MAKE MEANINGFUL CHANGES
THAT IMPACT AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF HOUSING COST AND
IS A STEP TOWARDS MAKING MORE
HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
MORE FAMILIES RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND WE WILL- LOOK
NOW FOR A MOTION ON THE BILL.
THE MOVE BY SENATOR CAFIERO AND
AWESOME CONSULTATIVE ROLL CALL
PLEASE. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CORTEZ HI COURTESY I'D
BATES. BATES HI KABHI.
COPYRIGHT EGGMAN. MCGUIRE I'M
SORRY A MAN I. A MAN I REQUIRE.
OCTOBER A TROUBLED EYES SCANNER.
SKINNER I AM BURKE- BURGER FI
WITH CAL SKI WITH HUSKY I.
EIGHT ZERO. EIGHT EIGHT ZERO
WE'LL KEEP THAT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBER- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE
WERE GOING TO GO BACK NOW. TWO
EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY ONE FIVE
ALTARS TAKING A PRESENTER IS
GONNA BE SENATOR SKINNER.
SINNER SKINNER- WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY PRESENT. A MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS. EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY ONE- HEAD FIRST I WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S OR
RATHER ON BEHALF OF A FAMILY
MEMBER TAKING THE AUTHOR.
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS TO ESTABLISH SEVERAL
SEVERAL PARAMETERS TO THE
PROGRAM. NOW THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL IS TO HELP OUR
HOMEOWNERS AND ESPECIALLY OUR
LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS BE ABLE
TO BUILD ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS AND IT'S YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE HAS EMBRACED-
BASICALLY GREEN LIGHTING
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS
THROUGHOUT THE- STATE. TO HELP
US DEAL WITH OUR HOUSING CRISIS
AND THE BENEFIT OF ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS IN ADDITION TO
THE FACT THAT THEY PROVIDE A
HOUSING UNIT IS THAT FOR MANY
STRUGGLING HOMEOWNERS IT ALSO
ALLOWS THEM TO REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES BECAUSE- THEY CAN. GET
THE RENTAL INCOME FROM THE S.
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT HOWEVER
WE FOUND THAT THERE ARE. A
NUMBER OF HOMEOWNERS FOR
VARIETY OF REASONS TO HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING FINANCING TO
BUILD SUCH UNITS AND THIS BABY
FIVE SIX ONE REQUIRES THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO HELP. TO
DEVELOP A HELP HOMEOWNERS IN
NEW HOUSING PROGRAM BY APRIL
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
ASSIST HOMEOWNERS WITH A
POIGNANCY. IT ALSO ADDS
GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
PARTICIPATION INCLUDING SETTING
ASIDE A PORTION OF THE
ASSISTANCE. FOR FOLKS THAT ARE
AT OR BELOW A 100% A. M. Y.
REQUIRING THE RENTAL OR LEASE
OF THE USE BUILT UNDER THE
PROGRAM. TO ANOTHER WORDS FOR
THAT IT MUST BE RENTED OR
LEASED FOR AT LEAST TWO YEARS.
AND PROHIBITING BALLOON
REPAYMENT PLANS TO PROTECT
HOMEOWNERS IT- INCLUDE SECOND
MORTGAGES OR BRANCH AS PROGRAM
FINANCING OPTIONS THAT THE
TREASURER COULD CONSIDER. SO
THE BILL COMPLEMENTS CURRENT
EFFORTS WITH THE TREASURER AND
FANNIE MAE TO UPDATE FEDERAL
LOAN GUIDANCE AND CREATE SPACE
FOR EIGHTY YEARS AND WITH THAT
I'D LIKE MY WITNESS KELLY
FALLON. WHO'S A SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER FROM THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL TO PRESENT. OKAY THANK
YOU SENATOR KELLY FELL IN IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU YES HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KELLY
COLIN I'M A SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER AT THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
WHICH IS A PUBLIC POLICY AFTER
THE ORGANIZATION. REPRESENTING
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE
AREA BUSINESSES THAT ARE
WORKING TO SOLVE OUR REGION'S
MOST CHALLENGING ISSUES. AND WE
ARE PROUD SPONSORED EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY ONE WOULD SUGGEST D.
BARRIERS. REMAIN FOR HOMEOWNERS
TO FINAL DEFEAT VERY HELPFUL.
THE IT WOULD. TO EASE THE
PROCESS. OF BUILDING THE USING
TWENTY SIXTEEN. AND I THINK
COUNTRY SONOMA COUNTY COUNTY
REDUCED PARKING REQUIREMENTS.
DISCRETIONARY PERMITTING AN
ONEROUS UTILITY CONNECTION
PIECE THAT MADE BUILDING EIGHT
YEARS IN PEOPLE THE HOMEOWNERS.
WERE ALSO CO FOUNDERS OF THE
CASITA COALITION WHICH IS A
STATE WIDE MULTI SECTOR
INTERNATIONAL WORKING TO REMOVE
POLICY BARRIERS PEOPLE EACH.
EACH INJECTION I BECAME LAW THE
STATE HAS PASSED NUMEROUS LAWS
EITHER PROCESS. TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT BY THE UC BERKELEY
TURNER CENTER FOUND THAT YOU
PERMIT INCREASE FROM SIX
THOUSAND AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
TO EIGHTEEN THOUSAND AND TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND I'M NOT SAYING.
YOU COMPLETIONS INCREASED FROM
APPROXIMATELY TWO THOUSAND.
SEVEN PROBLEMS. IT IS
NOTICEABLE THAT THIS IS THE
ONLY TYPE OF HOUSING THAT'S
EXPERIENCING. AN INCREASE IN
HARMONY IN CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY. AND WHILE A NEW
PERMITTING COMPLETION TIME SPAN
SHE COULD SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE
STATE. A MAJOR BARRIER REMAINS
FOR HOMEOWNERS WITH LOWER
INCOME WORK YOUR ASSETS THAT
ARE UNABLE TO FIND ACTIVITIES.
TODAY HOMEOWNERS TYPICALLY
TRANSFER REVIEWS USING EXISTING
CASH SEATING. HOME EQUITY LOAN
OR REFINANCING. THESE OPTIONS
ARE PRIMARILY AVAILABLE TO
HOMEOWNERS WITH HIGH INCOME OR
HIGH HOME EQUITY. MAYBE LOWER
INCOME HOMEOWNERS HOMEOWNERS.
WITHOUT FINANCING OPTION FOR
THE WEEK. THREE SIX CYLINDER
PERMIT LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS IN
HOMEOWNERS A COLOR TO EIGHTY. A
RECENT YOU SHOULD SAID
CHRISTINE. STUDIES THAT EIGHTY
OWNERS TEND TO BE MORE MORE.
THEY ARE LESS LIKELY THAN I HAD
TO PERSON OF COLOR COMPARED TO
TYPICAL. HOMEOWNER IF YOU TRY
TO SHE WANTED TO. K. MY DIRECT
THE TREASURE TO WORK WITH THE
BROAD GROUP OF. TO STOP AN
ANSWER. EIGHTY USING A GREAT
POTENTIAL FOR EIGHTY. RIGHT
PORTABLE RIGHT OPTIONS
CALIFORNIA. ENTER INCOME FOR
HOMEOWNERS. THE STATION. THIS
FOR THE ALL HOMEOWNERS ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS IT. ARE STRICTLY
OSCAR IDLE THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- WE'RE GOING TO. COME
BACK HERE TO- TO THIS
PARTICULAR ROOM AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE GALLERY
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF A. B. FIVE SIXTY ONE IF SO.
YOU MAY STEP FORWARD AT THIS
TIME AS SEEN NONE I WILL CHECK
YOUR FULL ROOM FOR WITNESSES-
THERE NONE THERE. A LITTLE
MODERATOR NOW SMARTER TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY. SUPPORT WITNESSES
ON EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY ONE. AND
PLEASE GIVE US A NUMBER IF YOU
HAVE A- CERTAINLY IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH THREE LINES IN
Q. LINE ONE ON THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SAYS THE MATTER NOT LAST PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE PAYMENTS GO. UP PLANNING AN
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION ON
ITS- FIELD SETTING COMPANY
CALIFORNIAN B. AND THE COMPUTER
COALITION ALL INSURANCE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINETY EIGHT. THAT
YOUR SHARE NUMBERS ALEX
SORENSON- ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. FIFTY THREE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BAR AND
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO ARE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. TWO ADDITIONAL LINES
ONE THIRTY SIX. LOOKING IN
CHINA MEMBERS KIMBERLY DONE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND THE BOARD ABOUT. NINE ONE
THIRTY THREE. HI ALLISON
SCHALLERT CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES STORY FROM THE FRONT
LINES AND PROBABLY WOULD
FORWARD AND- RIGHT THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES AND
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
YOUR MODERATOR- WE'LL CHECK FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY NOW
THERE'S NO LINK THERE'S NO
IDENTIFY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ALASKA THERE'S ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS AN OPPOSITION POSITION
TO MAYBE FIVE SIXTY ONE. I'VE
SEEN NONE. I WILL CHECK YOUR
FULL ROOM AGAIN FOR WITNESSES.
BUT NONE THERE AND WE'LL COME
BACK TO THE MODERATOR.
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. TO EIGHTY
FIVE SIXTY ONE AND AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE KNOWING THE NUMBER
THANK YOU. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
STATE YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
THIS ONE AND THEN ZERO. TURN
ONLINE TO QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
AND- WE WILL COME BACK NOW TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON A.
B. FIVE SIXTY ONE RECOGNIZE
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE FIRST THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I KNOW THAT.
MY OFFICES HAD DISCUSSIONS FOR
PROBABLY TWO YEARS WITH THE
HOUSING A CALIFORNIA HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE THE SICK CONCERNS ON
FINANCING- WITH THEIR CREDIT
RATING AND WITH THEIR FRIENDS
FREDDIE MAC AND FANNIE MAE WILL
ALLOW- LOANS TO GO THROUGH SO I
APPRECIATE THE PARTS OF THE-
BILL THAT REQUIRED THE TREASURY
TO CONSULT WITH. AND T. S. H.
C. D. N. THE CALIFORNIA FINANCE
FINANCING HOUSING FINANCING
AGENCY EVEN THOUGH THE
FINANCING AGENCY SHALL NOT BE
AFFILIATED WITH THIS. SO I
THINK WE'RE GONNA GET TO THE
TICKET THERE MY QUESTION IS
WELL IT'S CALLED A HELP
HOMEOWNERS ADD NEW HOUSING
PROGRAM- I WAS WONDERING IF THE
PRESENTER. KNEW THAT IF. RE
HAVE A D. USE THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE'S BEEN A DETERMINATION BY
THE LOCAL. AUTHORITIES THAT
IT'S NOT SAFE AND HABITABLE SO
IT'S KNOCKED OUT OF THE HOUSING
IF THEY WOULD QUALIFY FOR ONE
OF THESE LOANS TO BRING. IN MY
UNDERSTANDING ADDITIONAL
HOUSING UNITS BACK ON TO THE
MARKET IF THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN
PUMPED OUT OF FOR THE BOOTLEG
UNITS. THE SOONER SCHOONER DID
YOU WANT TO ATTEMPT IT
RESPONDED TO A QUESTION OR- A
DEFERRED TO THE LEAD WITNESS
PERHAPS. RESPOND IN THAT TOWN.
IN MY READ OF THE TEXT OF THE
BILL. THERE DOES NOT APPEAR TO
BE AN EXCLUSION FOR THAT
HOWEVER IT IS NOT EXPLICITLY
INCLUDED SO I THINK THAT MIGHT
END UP BEING. PART OF A.
WHETHER THE TREASURER IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PROGRAM-
PURSUES IT. THE TITLE NEW
HOUSING IS OF COURSE ONLY A
TITLE IN ISN'T NECESSARILY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE STATUTE SO-
MY ANSWER IS THAT HI I THINK
IT'S ONE OF THOSE GRAY AREAS
WHERE IT DOES NOT. EXPLICITLY
INCLUDE IT BUT IT DOES NOT
EXCLUDE ARMED AND I CERTAINLY
SEE THE POINT OF THE- OF
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE CAN ASKING
THE QUESTION BECAUSE- PRIOR TO
HIS GOOD WORK AND OTHERS IN IN.
GETTING EIGHTY USE TO BE
ACCEPTED BY OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ALLOWED. THERE
WERE ISSUES THEY JUST HOWEVER
WERE ILLEGAL SO THEY WERE
ILLEGAL GRANNY FLATS. AND THERE
ARE YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT IF
WE CAN TO SUPPORT TRYING TO GET
THOSE TO MEET CODE AND BE LEGAL
SO THEY CAN BE GOOD HOUSING
UNITS SO I APPRECIATE THE
INTENT. THOUGH I THINK SOME OF
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE IN
INTERACTIONS WITH THE
TREASURER'S OFFICES THEY
DEVELOPED THE PROGRAM AND OF
COURSE THERE IT'S GIVEN
DEPENDING ON HOW THE FINANCING
IS DEVELOPED. WHETHER THAT
FINANCING YOU KNOW IT WOULD BE
IF IT AGAIN THERE'S FANNIE MAE
AND FREDDIE MAC ISSUES THERE'S
VARIOUS ISSUE SO ALL OF THOSE
WOULD HAVE TO BE WORKED OUT BUT
I CAN CERTAINLY SEE A VALUE TO
WHAT. SENATOR Y. SKI RACE AND
MISTER CHAIR AT THE HI I WOULD
JUST MAKE THE DISTINCTION IF
YOU HAVE AN EXISTING EIGHTY YOU
AND IT'S AND IT MEETS ALL THE
SAFETY. A SAFETY AND HEALTHY-
REQUIREMENTS. AND YOU WANT TO.
OUR MONEY TO THIS IT UP WITH
THE PAINTED I DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE PART OF THIS PROGRAM
THAT'S YOUR OWN VEHICLE JUST
LIKE YOU WANT TO PAINT YOUR
HOUSE BUT IF YOU IF THERE'S
BEEN A DETERMINATION. THAT IT'S
NOT THAT IT'S NO LONGER CO
HABIT OF NORTH THEN THEY WOULD
I WOULD HOPE THAT THE TREASURE
AND THE FOLKS THAT ARE. TRYING
TO INTERPRET THIS WOULD SAY
pHOUSING AS HE COUNTS AS WE
COUNT FOR RENO OR WITH OTHER
PURPOSES- IF. THEY NEED A
MOTION I WILL MAKE IT. ORIGINAL
SAUCE HE DULY NOTED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND- WILL COME BACK
TO YOU- TO FORMALIZE THE MOTION
AFTER. BUT WE CHECK TO SEE IF
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO BE
RECOGNIZED- TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY ONE.
THIS IS FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME- SCENE NINE CENTER
SCANNER YOU MAY CLOSE. I N. I
WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO
SENATOR CASKEY IS BEING THE-
FIRST LEGISLATOR TO REALLY PUSH
THIS- THIS- GREEN LIGHTING OF
USE AND OF COURSE THERE'S BEEN
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION BUT AS
WE HEARD FROM THE TESTIMONY IT
HAS BEEN AMAZING SUCCESS STORY.
WE HAVE ADDED A GREAT DEAL OF
HOUSING UNITS AND WHAT I WOULD
NOTE THE- THAT MIGHT LEAD LEAD
WITNESS DID NOT INDICATE THAT
THAT TURNER STUDY POINTED OUT
SO ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT RAISE ABOUT EIGHTY
USES WELL YOU KNOW IF THEIR
CHEST STUDIOS OR WHATEVER. ARE
THEY REALLY ASSISTING US TO GET
FAMILY HOUSING BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE TURNER STUDY
SHOWED IS THAT LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS. THE EIGHTY USE THAT
THEY PROVIDE TEND TO BE FAMILY
UNITS AND THEY TEND TO BE AT A
AT A RENTED AT AFFORDABLE RATES
SO THE MORE THAT WE CAN ASSIST
A LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS BE ABLE
TO. ACHIEVE AN EIGHTY YOU THEN
WE ARE ADDING FAMILY HOUSING
UNITS AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THIS FINANCING PROGRAM REALLY
WOULD DO. AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. FOUR TAKE
THE SENATORS- WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR WHITE CASKET ON
EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY ONE TURN THE
CONSOLE FOR THE ROLL CALL. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIXTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
C. CORTEZ HE I'D BATES. BATES
NOW COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT EGGMAN.
MCGUIRE OCTOBER THE TROUBLED
NOW SKINNER SKINNER HI NUMBER
NUMBER FIVE WE CAN SKI WITH
HUSKY I. FIVE TO TWO. THREE
FIVE TWO TWO AND LEAVE THE BILL
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU. YEAH WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO A. B. NINE EIGHT NINE
NINE EIGHTY NINE- SOME NUMERIC
OKAY. IF YOU'RE HERE YOU MAY UP.
PROCEED TO PRESENT THIS SOMBER
LIVED- SOMEONE GABRIEL I RUSSIA
BOWED TO GO IN IN THIS ORDER IT
BUT- IT JUST OUT OF A- NUMBER
OF REASONS- HE ELECTED TO ALLOW
ME TO PROCEED IF YOU DON'T
MIND- NO OBJECTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR OKAY LET ME JUST BE CLEAR
THAT THIS IS NOW A. B. NINE
SIXTY FIVE AUTHORS LEVIN AND
THAT'S- THE BILL WILL BE HERE
AND AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THAT'S RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN VERSION.
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY FIVE WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO CONSIDER
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
SPACES AT EXISTING MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS TO TWENTY PERCENT. OF
THE AVAILABLE PARKING AT THE
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS YOUR
PART OF THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION TO RESEARCH AND
DEVELOP BUILDING STANDARDS FOR
INSTALLATION. FOR FUTURE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PARKING
SPACES FOR EXISTING NON
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT AS WELL
COMBUSTION POWERED VEHICLES ARE
THE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN AN EFFORT TO
REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S CARBON
FOOTPRINT. GOVERNOR NEWSOM
ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
PHASE OUT THIS. OF NEW COMBAT
ENGINE VEHICLES TWENTY FIVE. TO
COM THIS GOAL THE CAL ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS ASKED ME THAT
HOW WILL NEED. ONE POINT FIVE
NO YOU CHARGE. THIS DR
TRANSITION EV'S IN THE COMING
DECADES. REQUIRING EEVEE READY
PARKING SPACES AT MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS IN
CONSIDERING THE ADDITIONAL TV
CHARGING. WHEN AN EXISTING
BUILDING REQUIRES A BUILDING OR
ELECTRICAL PERMIT FOR
CONSTRUCTION. OR THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE METHODS TO FACILITATE
BROAD DEPLOYMENT. OF EVEY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE THIS
MEASURE IS NECESSARY TO PROVIDE
CLEAR GUIDANCE TO ENSURE. THE
EQUITABLE AND SWIFT
DEVELOPMENT. APARTMENT
DEPLOYMENT OF EVEY CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA IN BOTH MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING AND COMMERCIAL
PROPERTIES. AS CALIFORNIA MOVES
TOWARD AN ALL EASY FUTURE
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY FIVE WILL
ENSURE THAT THE NECESSARY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN
PLACE TO ACCOMMODATE THE
GROWING NUMBER OF TV'S ON OUR
STREETS. ROADS AND HIGHWAYS ARE
STRICTLY ASKED FOR AN IPO THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN AND- THREE
FOOT MY PAGE OVER HERE MAKE
SURE I'M- A KNOWLEDGE GENE-
YOUR LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE CHRISTIAN
CORBY- AND DYLAN JOB
DESCRIPTION CORBY AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY. ARTICLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS CHRISTIAN CORBIN ON-
DEPUTY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AT
THE CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION-
COMMONLY KNOWN AS KELLY TO SEE.
HELLO DC IS THE NONPROFIT TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT COMMITTED TO
THE SUCCESSFUL INTRODUCTION AND
LARGE SCALE DEPLOYMENT OF ALL
FORMS OF ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION. AND OUR MEMBERS
INCLUDE UTILITIES AUTOMAKERS
AND ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
PROVIDERS. WE SUPPORT EIGHTY
NINE SIXTY FIVE WHICH PROVIDES
THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION WITH THE AUTHORITY
TO RESEARCH AND IMPLEMENT
BUILDING STANDARDS THAT
FACILITATE EASY CHARGING AT
EXISTING NON RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS. AND WOULD REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO
CONSIDER A MINIMUM TARGET OF
20% OF PARKING SPACES. AN
EXISTING MULTI FAMILY DWELLINGS
OR ANY DESIRE TO SUPPORT THE
FUTURE INSTALLATION OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING- EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY FIVE WILL HELP REMOVE A
SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO GREATER
AND MORE EQUITABLE ADOPTION OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED GOVERNOR SIMS
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND THE STATE
HAS ADOPTED SOME VERY AMBITIOUS
GOALS FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES
INCLUDING A FIVE MILLION
ELECTRIC VEHICLES BY TWENTY
THIRTY. TO ACHIEVING THESE
GOALS WILL REQUIRE A
SIGNIFICANT SCALE UP OF
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE SO IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADDRESSED A KEY BARRIER TO
CHARGING ACCESS EXISTING. M. U.
D. AND R. INTRODUCTION SOMEONE
ON. AT THE AT A WORKSHOP IN
FEBRUARY POSTED BY- THE HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT- STAFF
STATED THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE A
THE NECESSARY STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO ADOPT STANDARDS
FOR EXISTING BUILDINGS HOWEVER.
ACT HAS A PRESENTABLE 410% ET
CHARGING REQUIREMENTS IN
EXISTING AMIDES ARE TRIGGERED
BY WORK AT A PARKING FACILITY.
OF HCV HAS UNDERSCORED THE
TERRITORY IS LIMITED AN EIGHTY
NINE SIXTY FIVE- IS DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE TO THIS ISSUE. AND
WILL ADDRESS A KEY BARRIER TO
CHARGING ACCESS. TO HELP INSURE
THAT EV'S ARE VIABLE OPTION FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IDOL TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY. DILLINGER OFFER YOU
BUILD TEST FOR. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS DYLAN
JAFFA BEHALF ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING ASSOCIATION. ON
SUPPORT BABY NINE SIXTY FIVE
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION OR AFRICA IS A NOT
FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
BRINGS TOGETHER LEADERS
THROUGHOUT THE VALUE CHAIN OF
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INDUSTRY TO ADVANCE THAT GOAL
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. WE
LIKE TO TAKE A FAMILY MEMBER
LIVING IN THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY FIVE AM IS AN
ESSENTIAL PIECE TO HELPING THE
STATE ACHIEVE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE DEPLOYMENT
GOALS. BY DRESSING MINIMUM EVEY
READY PARKING INCREASE BEING
MULTI UNIT DWELLINGS URBAN
MOBILITY HUBS. WE WILL CONTINUE
TO ALIGN WITH THE WHITE
OBJECTIVES OF INCREASING
ACCESSIBILITY TO EVEY
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE
STATE. EIGHTY NINE FIFTY FIVE
TAKES A REASONABLE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUE YOU READY
PARKING SPACES. IN EXISTING
BUILDINGS ONLY ONE OTHER
CONSTRUCTION IS ALREADY
OCCURRING. WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL ULTIMATELY REDUCE TOTAL
COST OF THE CHARGING STATION.
RELATIVE TO THE INSTALLATION OF
AN EEVEE. CHARGING STATION IN
ISOLATION. AGAIN WE YOU ALL FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS ISSUE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I.
WILL WRITE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- WE'LL CHECK WITH THE
GALLERY DOWN TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE PRESENT WHO WISHES
TO TAKE A SUPPORT POSITION ON
THIS BILL- AGAIN THIS IS-
AUTHOR LIVING. IN IT IS- AB
NINE SIXTY FIVE C. NONSTOP FOR
WILL CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THAT ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY I WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR. AND ASKED THE
MODERATOR. BUT THE PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY WITNESSES. WHO WERE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
FIVE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON THE TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. AGAIN NOT TO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO HAVE
TWO LINES IN Q. LOCAL FIRSTLINE.
ONE FIFTY FOUR. YES TO CHERISH
THE COMMITTEE POLICY ON BEHALF.
IN SUPPORT OF. NINETY FIVE.
FIND. ONE FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JUSTIN
HIERARCHICAL COMBAT LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER ALLIANCE
AND SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR-
THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION BUT
WITNESSES WITNESS IDENTIFIED.
ON THIS BILL WE WILL ASK OTHERS
IN THE GALLERY WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS AN OPPOSITION POSITION
ON A. B. NINE SIXTY FIVE. THE
SCENE NO ONE STEP FORWARD- WE
WILL LOOK TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM
IN CONFIRM THAT THERE'S NO ONE
THERE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY.
BUT WILL NOW GO BACK TO THE
MODERATOR IN ASSAM MODERATED
CHECK TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION WISHES TO SPEAK
ON THE TELECONFERENCE ON A. B.
NINE SIXTY FIVE. SURE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AB NINE
SIXTY FIVE. PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE THAT'S ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANKS AGAIN MODERATOR AND
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK NOW TO
THE COMMITTEE ASK THERE'S ANY
COMMENT- FROMCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD-
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO. HE
COULD ENTER BY SHARE BAITS- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO. I GUESS I'M JUST
A QUICK QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
I HAVE THERE BEEN ANY ANALYSIS
OF ANY OF THE COST OF IT-
IMPACT ON. LOVE YOU KNOW THE
BUILDING OF HOUSING UP
REQUIRING DEVELOPERS TO PROVIDE
THEIR FIGHT IN BOTH COMMERCIAL
AND I GUESS MOVING INTO
RESIDENTIAL. I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT JOB THE ISSUE THAT WE
NEED TO DO DEAL WITH IN THE
PRESIDENT. PAUL AS WE'RE TRYING
TO FOCUS ON CREATING THE
HOUSING. AND ESPECIALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I KNOW THAT
YOU CHOOSE WITH. THE CHARGING
STATIONS ARE ARE HUGE BAT TOP
IF IT I JUST THINK IT MIGHT BE
KIND OF PREMATURE ALSO IF WE
HAVE A NUMBER THAT WOULD HELP
ME UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE- MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION ON AT THE
PRESENT. YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR
BATES FOR THAT QUESTION IT
REALLY BRINGS ME BACK TO- THE
HISTORY THAT'S WRITTEN OUT IN.
THE ANALYSIS BY MISS RICHES
WHERE SHE MENTIONS THE NOW
SUSPENSIONS MY BILL FROM.
TWENTY THIRTEEN- TEN NINETY.
AND WHERE THAT CONVERSATION
TOOK PLACE AND I KNOW THAT'S A
VERY LONG TIME AGO. THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION BUT BACK IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN THAT WAS WHEN
THIS CONVERSATION THAT YOU'RE
MENTIONING WAS OCCURRING. AND
IT AND IT WAS A NEGLIGIBLE COST
AND IN FACT. BUILDERS ACTUALLY
SAW VALUE IN PROVIDING THIS-
BECAUSE THEY SAW WHAT THE
FUTURE WOULD HOLD AND SO IT
IT'S NOT AN ISSUE TODAY. THANK
YOU YOU HAVE THE FOUR OF US
YOUR BASES OR ANYTHING ELSE. I
KNOW THANKS- OKAY THANK YOU-
CINECA EURO DID YOU WISH TO
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I
AM I READ THIS RIGHT BECAUSE-
WHILE I ATE. I THINK IT'S
REALLY- THERE'S A NEED TO- DO
THE EEVEE CHARGING STATIONS IN
NEW CONSTRUCTION MY CONCERN IS-
ALTERATION DEMOLITION REPAIR OR
ADDITION. TO MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING. UNITS AND- IT'S ALWAYS
A LOT MORE EXPENSIVE TO
RETROFIT SOMETHING THEN IT TO
BUILD IT THE FIRST TIME. AND
WHEN YOU'RE GOING IN IN YOUR
YOUR IF YOU'RE DEMOLISHING AND
BUILDING A NEW BUILDING THAT
IT'S A NEW BUILDING AND I'M NOT
WORRIED ABOUT THAT BUT WHAT I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT- IN
PARTICULAR. IN MY COMMUNITY
HAVE A LOT OF REALLY OLD
APARTMENTS. THAT ON THEIR BEST
THEY DON'T LOOK ALL THAT GREAT
AND- THERE'S ALWAYS A NEED FOR.
FOR REPAIR WETHER IT'S A ROUGH
OR A PARKING STRUCTURE OR A-
PARKING LOT. AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT WHETHER THIS. GIVES
AUTOMATIC. APPROVAL TO REQUIRE
UP 220% OF THE PARKING SPACES
IN EXISTING MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS- IF ANY PERMIT IS
PULLED AND AS AS YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A PERMIT FOR
ANYTHING THAT YOU DO ON IN AT
AN APARTMENT YOU PUT IN NEW
HEATERS NEW VENTURE INTO ROUGH
ALL OF THAT REQUIRES IT RIGHT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER
THIS IS AN AUTOMATIC IN OTHER
WORDS DID IT GIVES THEM THE-
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE IT. UP
220% YEAH I THOUGHT YOU KNOW
WE- TALKED ABOUT A BUILDING OR
ELECTRICAL PERMIT. DOWN AS I
HAD MENTIONED I CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
OFFICE ABOUT WHETHER THE ITEMS
THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT I
MEAN THE HEATER DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE A VERY SERIOUS THING BUT
IF YOU'RE UPGRADING AN
ELECTRICAL PANEL THIS MAKES
SENSE TO. FICTIONALISED FULL
PANEL AS WE KNOW FROM THE
CAPITOL GARAGE CAN HANDLE A
LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA LOAD- SO WE
CAN WE CAN MAKE SURE TO GET
THAT INFORMATION TO YOU. I
THINK WHAT IS SIGNIFICANT TO
THE POINT THAT I MADE TO
SENATOR FACES QUERY IS THAT.
OPPOSITION WITH THOSE TYPES OF
CONCERNS PARTICULARLY FROM
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCATES
TIME DID NOT ARISE- AS WE
DEVELOP THE SPILL- AND SO YOU
KNOW WE WILL BE. YEAH I'M GLAD
TO BE IN CONSULTATION WITH OUR
STAFF TO BE MORE SPECIFIC. TO
THAT PARTICULAR QUERY. WELL I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION AND
THAT'S ALWAYS THAT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT LET ME JUST SAY THAT
ALL ALL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BUT I WANNA HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT BECAUSE- I DON'T WANT
APARTMENT. UNITS TO BE IMPROVED
MMHM BECAUSE THEN IT TRIGGERS.
SOMETHING THAT THAT THEY NEVER
INTENDED AND I JUST HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT. IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA I DON'T SEE VERY
MANY ELECTRIC VEHICLES PERIOD.
AND WE HAD A VERY IMPASSIONED
SPEECH ON THE FLOOR THIS
MORNING AND I KNOW I'M NOT
GOING TO QUOTE IT EXACTLY RIGHT
BUT- ONE OF MY GOOD COLLEAGUES-
COMMENTED THAT OUR ELECTRIC
VEHICLE. GRAHAM IT PROVIDES
COVERAGE FOR THE RICH AND- DOES
NOT. PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
WORKING WORKING FOLKS IN
PARTICULAR PEOPLE OF COLOR TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD- A VEHICLE
THAT THAT SERVES THEIR NEEDS-
IN RECOVERING SO I WELL I WILL
SUPPORT THIS TODAY I HAVE REAL
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
EVER GONNA REACH DOWN FAR
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO GET. ON A
THE PROGRAM TO WORK SO THAT
WE'RE WE'RE OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY ARE ARE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THAT. IN IN AREAS WHERE
THEY HAVE THE WORST AIR QUALITY
WHICH SHOULD BE THE SOUTH COAST
AND THE- THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
TO REQUIRE LANDLORDS. TO START
IMPLEMENTING THESE KINDS OF
PROGRAMS WHEN THEY DO AN
UPGRADE. AND HAVE THEM SIT.
EMPTY DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO
ME SO- I'M I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT MOVING TOO FAR AHEAD OF
WHERE WE'RE WHERE IT'S GOING TO
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN THE
URBAN AREAS TO MAKE MAKE ME
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE BUT IN IN
MY AREA I DON'T I DON'T SEE IT
AND I'VE- I'VE BEEN LOOKING
VERY CAREFULLY SO APPRECIATE
WHATYOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE.
I SUPPORT THE IDEAS I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
REQUIRING 20% OF THE- THE
SPACES TO BE USED WHEN IN
REALITY THEY THEY WON'T GET
USED USED FOR THE PURPOSE FOR
WHICH WE PUT IN ALL THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR POINT AND I
THINK FOR US TO HAVE A CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE THAT WE MUST HAVE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES SHOULD BE FOR
EVERYBODY. AND THE ABILITY TO
USE ELECTRIC VEHICLES MUST BE
PRESENT FOR EVERYBODY- THIS IS
AND I JUST WANNA MAKE A POINT
JUST FOR THE UNDERLYING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE IN PLACE
NOT ACTUAL CHARGERS SO THAT
WHEN THE DEMAND IS THERE THAT
IS WHEN IT WILL BE AVAILABLE-
RATHER THAN BEING LECTURED-
CHARGERS THAT WILL JUST SAID-
UNUSED VERY GOOD I APPRECIATE
THAT DISTINCTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH. OUR
SOUTHWESTERN IDAHO. OKAY IS
THERE A MOTION ON THE BILL. C.
B. NINE SIXTY FIVE. ALL RIGHT
SERVICE CENTER REQUIRE MOVES TO
BUILD CONSULTANT WILL CALL THE
ROLL THIS TIME THANK YOU. THIS
IS THE SUM OF ALL NINE SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER COURTESY
HI CORTESE I'D BATES. COPYRIGHT
COPYRIGHT- AIKMAN MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE I- CHILL BOOK A
TROUBLED EYES SCANNER. SKINNER
BURKE- BURGER WITH CAL SKI WITH
HUSKY I I'M SORRY SENATOR PETER
YOU'RE NOT BETTING. TYLER IT'S
NOT VOTING. SEVEN ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. I JUST WANNA IS
NECESSARY TO KEEP THAT BILL ON
COLD IN HERE WE WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL FOR ANY ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FRESHER NUMBERS OKAY-
JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE I WANT
TO. CONSULT ON THE REMAINING
ORDER THE AGENDA. OKAY JUST
CONFIRMING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
STICK WITH- THE FOLLOW ORDER
THE REST OF THE WAY- IN- THAT
WOULD BRING US TO. A B. NINE
EIGHTY NINE. AUTHOR ON THAT
BILL IS ASSUMING MEMBER GABRIEL
IN- THE SUMMER BEFORE. BUT YOU
PRESENT I WANTED TO GIVE
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SOME
OPENING COMMENTS SENATOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER CHAIR
AND FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY SOME VERY
BRIEF COMMENTS I WANT TO SAY MR
KERR HOW GRATEFUL I AM AND I
KNOW. THAT AT YOUR WIENER IS
OBVIOUS IN THEM- GABRIEL THAT
HE'S BEEN WORKING PREVIOUSLY ON
THIS ISSUE- EVER SINCE- IT'S
LEFT THE ASSEMBLY WITH BOTH
MYSELF AS WELL AS CHAIR WINNER
OF HOUSING MYSELF. AS A
GOVERNING GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE CHAIR. AND WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BE CONTINUED ISSUES WITH
THIS BILL- IF THIS BILL LEAVES
COMMITTEE TODAY AND AT CENTRE
WEINER AND I ARE WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY TO BE AT A SET
UP A PROCESS THAT ALLOWS US.
ALL MYSELF A SITTER WINNER
ALONG WITH MR GABRIEL TO BE HAD
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BILL- IT'S AN IMPORTANT ONE I
KNOW THAT IT IS IMPORTANT ONE
TO- TO GET REAL AS WELL AS WELL
AS THE HOUSING IN THE STATE.
AND I JUST WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT I WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE SIM NUMBER
WHICH I KNOW HE IS COMMITTED TO
ACCEPT PAYMENTS IN IN ALICE'S
CONTINGENT. ON AGREEMENT WITH
BOTH AT THE CHAIR OF HOUSING
CENTER WINNER MYSELF THE CHAIR
OF GOVERNANCE IN FINANCE AS HE
PROCEEDS IN AGAIN MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I JUST
WANT TO RECOGNIZE. SOME MEMBER
GABRIEL FOR HIS INCREDIBLE
WORK. HIS TENACITY IN HIS
COLLABORATION AS HIS BILLS
MOVING FORWARD AS WELL AS THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFF WHO
HAVE BEEN GOING ABOVE AND
BEYOND. ON THIS SO REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP.
WITH REQUIRED ME TO SAY UP A-
S. QUESTION PUT SOMETHING ON
THE RECORD HERE. AND DESTROY TO
MY THE COMMIT. BECAUSE A
DOCUMENT THAT SAYS A MAN MUST
BE TAKEN AS AN APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CONTINGENT UPON
AGREEMENT BETWEEN SENATE HOUSE
AND SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. AND SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIRS IN THEIR
SEVEN. ENUMERATED PARAGRAPH
SAYS WANNA MAKE SURE THESE ARE
THE MOMENTS THAT YOU WERE
REFERRING TO. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR YOU WERE A 100%
CORRECT THOSE ARE THE MOMENTS
AND REFERRING TO THANK YOU MR
CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR-
WILL NOW GO UP TO SOME
REMEMBER. A GABRIEL- I JUST
BEFORE YOU PROCEED TO PRESENT I
JUST WANT TO INSURE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND. THE SAME ENUMERATED
LIST OF SEVEN AMENDMENT SAYS OF
THE DOCUMENT. BUT THAT YOU'RE
IN AGREEMENT TO- GOING FORWARD
AND- IF YOU COULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AND WE CAN GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED WITH THE
PRESENTATION. THAT'S CORRECT
THANK YOU SIR. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND
YOU MAY APPOINT PRESENTER READY
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER TERRY WANNA THANK YOU
AND PARTICULARLY. EXPRESS MY
THANKS TO. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
FORK FOR HIS THOUGHTFUL
COLLABORATION AND LEADERSHIP-
AND JUST TO SAY OF A. CORRECT-
I GOING TO BE EX THE AMOUNT
OUTLINE IN THE NOW- UNDER. FIVE
IN THERE HE- ON THE DOCUMENT
THAT WAS JUST DISTRIBUTED. AND
THAT'S EXCEPT FOR THE PROVISION
LIMITING THE APPLICATION OF THE
OFFICE 2100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND THAT'S NUMBER FIVE
WHICH IS- WHICH IS STRIKING OUT
HERE ON THE ON THE PAGE. AND
ALSO COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
BOTH THE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE
HOUSING COMMITTEE GOING FORWARD
ON THESE THREE AMENDMENTS. THAT
ARE NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS HERE
AND ALSO. ON THE PAGE THAT WAS
DISTRIBUTED THAT REQUIRE THE
COLLABORATION OF THOSE
COMMITTEES AND FOR PURPOSES OF
THE RECORD. THOSE ARE MOMENTS
ONE FOUR AND SEVEN HERE ON THE
PAGE. AND IN ADDITION I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. ON ANY
COMMITMENT ON AMENDMENTS THAT.
IMPACT THE JURISDICTION OF THAT
COMMITTEE- SO SHOULD HAVE
PASSED TODAY- THE PLAN IS TO
AMEND THIS BILL IN THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CONTINGENT UPON THE AGREEMENT
OF ALL THREE SENATE CHAIRS. AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT IF AGREEMENT
IS NOT REACHED ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS BETWEEN THE THREE
CHAIRS. BUT I WILL NOT MOVE THE
BILL TO THE SENATE FLOOR BUT
JUST REALLY WANT TO EMPHASIZE
FIRST AND FOREMOST. HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK AND
THOUGHTFUL ASSISTANCE OF.
SENATOR MCGUIRE OF ANTON AND
HIS COMMITTEE OFFICE. OF
SENATOR WIENER. OF HIS
INCREDIBLE- THE STAFF. WHO HAVE
WORKED REALLY HARD ON THIS
ISSUE- ALLISON AND ERIN AND
THEN ALSO KRISTA IN CENTER
WINNERS PERSONAL STAFF AND JUST
REALLY APPRECIATE. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. ON THESE FINAL
ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO RESOLVE.
ANY PLEASE TODAY. MR TRY TO
PRESENT THE B. NINETY NINE.
WHICH WOULD CREATE A
SPECIALIZED APPEAL PANEL. TO
ADDRESS SITUATIONS WHERE LOCAL
OFFICIALS SEEK TO PREVENT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN VIOLATION OF STATE
LAW. THIS LEGISLATION IS AN
EFFORT TO STRENGTHEN THE
PURPOSE AND INTENT OF THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
INITIALLY PASSED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO THE HA AIMS TO
PREVENT EFFORTS TO BLOCK THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE OTHER FLIGHTS
COMPLIES WITH THE OPTICAL
GENERAL PLAN. ZONING AND
SUBDIVISION STANDARDS. AND
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
MAKE SPECIFIC FINDINGS IN THE
EVENT THAT THEY DO SO.
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE
CALIFORNIA'S WELL DOCUMENTED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS SOME
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE DEFIED
THE ACT. DENIED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS. EVEN WHEN
THEY ARE FULLY COMPLIANT WITH
ALL LOCAL ZONING AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. THESE OFFICIALS
UNDERSTAND THAT IN MOST CASES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROPONENTS
WILL HAVE NO PRACTICAL MEANS TO
CHALLENGE THE UNLAWFUL DENIALS.
AS THE CURRENT REMEDY.
LITIGATION IN SUPERIOR COURT IS
ALMOST ALWAYS PROHIBITIVELY
EXPENSIVE TIME CONSUMING AND
OTHERWISE IMPRACTICAL. B.
NINETY NINE WOULD ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM BY CREATING AN
ALTERNATE REVIEW PANEL WITH
SPECIALIZED EXPERTISE. MODELED
OFF AN APPROACH TO SUCCESSFULLY
BEEN IMPLEMENTED IN OTHER
STATES. THE JURISDICTION OF THE
REVIEW PANEL WOULD BE VERY
NARROW AND LIMITED TO ONE SOUL
ISSUE. WHETHER THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT VIOLATED THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT BY
DISAPPROVING A PROJECT WITHOUT
MAKING THE APPROPRIATE FINDINGS
AS REQUIRED BY LAW. THE PANEL
WOULD THUS BE ABLE TO RESOLVE
DISPUTES AROUND IMPROPER AND
UNLAWFUL DENIALS. IN A MORE
EXPEDITED LESS EXPENSIVE LESS
CONFRONTATIONAL AND MORE
CONSISTENT MANNER. TO BE CLEAR
A. B. NINETY NINE SIMPLY
PROVIDES A NEW PROCEDURAL
REMEDY TO RESOLVE DISPUTES IT
DOES NOT UP ZONE CHANGE ANY
LOCAL ZONING OR LAND USE
POLICIES. OR OTHERWISE CHANGE
SUBSTANTIVE STATE LAW AROUND
HOUSING. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THE FOLLOW STATE LAW GOOD FAITH
ARE UNLIKELY TO HAVE
INTERACTION WITH THIS NEW PANEL
WELL THOSE HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY
AND WILLFULLY VIOLATING THE LAW
WILL BE ENCOURAGED TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. WITH LESS
ADVERSARIAL AND MORE COST
EFFECTIVE APPROACH IS SUPPORTED
BY A COALITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING GROUPS HOUSING
ADVOCATES AND LOCAL FFICIALS.
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP. THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SACRAMENTO MAYOR
MAYOR DARRELL STEINBERG. WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR MARK
STIVERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND TONY
BELIEVE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU AND AT THE APPROPRIATE.
TIME WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN IPHONE. THE THANK YOU VERY-
IN THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
CLARIFICATIONS- THAT YOU MADE
AT THE OUTSET. OF ALL
APPRECIATED THINK BY. EVERYONE
HERE- WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
THOSE- LEAD WITNESSES. AT THIS
TIME. AND WE'LL START WITH MARK
STIVERS. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR- I MARCHED IRISH OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
THE PARTNERSHIP WAS CREATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADVISE ON
THE PRODUCTION AND PRESERVATION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
ADDITION WE PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO MOST OF THE
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS IN THE STATE. THE
PARTNERSHIP HEARS OFTEN FROM
OUR NONPROFIT DEVELOPER
PARTNERS THAT THEY WILL NOT
TAKE THE FINANCIAL RISK TO BUY
A PROPERTY THEY DON'T THINK
THEY CAN GET THROUGH THE LOCAL
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS AND THESE
PARTNERS HAVE EXPERIENCED A
GOOD NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE UNWELCOMING OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE EXISTING HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IN THEORY
PROTECTS DEVELOPERS FROM
ARBITRATED NILES RUN REASONABLE
CONDITIONS THAT MAKE THE
DEVELOPMENTS IN FEASIBLE AND WE
ARE APPRECIATIVE OF RECENT
CHANGES BY CENTER SCANNER TO
INCREASE PENALTIES UNDER THE
ACT. HOWEVER FOR OUR NONPROFIT
DEVELOPMENT PARTNERS THE ACTOR
MEANS A RELATIVELY EMPTY
PROTECTION OUR PARTNER SIMPLY
CANNOT SPEND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN LEGAL
FEES INTEREST AND ADDITIONAL
CARRYING COSTS AT LEAST TWO
YEARS OF THEIR TIME TO GO
THROUGH THE COURTS. AN
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS PROCESS
HAVE BEEN TRIED AND FOUND
SUCCESSFUL IN MASSACHUSETTS
WHERE IT'S BEEN IN PLACE SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE. RHODE
ISLAND ILLINOIS AND OREGON.
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS ACTUALLY
USE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESSES IN THE STATES. OUR
NONPROFIT PARTNERS TELL US IN A
B. NINETY NINE WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THE RISK
PROFILE GIVING THEM GREATER
CERTAINTY AND CONFIDENCE TO
BRING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROPOSALS FORWARD AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. GET THEM BUILT.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY NINE IS
ABOUT EFFICIENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND I AGAIN
EXPRESS MY THANKS TO THE TWO
POLICY COMMITTEE CHAIRS AND
THEN PRESS THE SAFF OF THE
MANY HOURS THEY'VE PUT IN TO
GET US HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY THANK YOUR
TESTIMONY- TONY BOUTIQUE- IF
YOU'RE HERE YOU MAY PROCEED IN
EARNEST AND YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
LINE. YOUR PICTURE. ON IT WILL
BE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. THE ASSOCIATION OF
THE FLORIDA STATE WIDE RENTAL
HOUSING TRADE ASSOCIATION THE
COUNTRY- REPRESENTING A
PORTABLE- AND MARKET RATE
RENTAL UNITS ACROSS THE STATE-
WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY NINE. KEEP
MY COMMENTS BRIEF- WE AGAIN.
LAST WEEK A WEEK AND YOU WILL
CONTROL. OF LOCAL JURISDICTION.
ITS OWN CURRENCY ALL DAY. IF
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO WORRY
ABOUT. THIS NEW- MAYBE ONLY
WILL LOOK AT IT LOOK AT YOUR-
WHICH- THE PROJECT THAT WAS NOT
EVEN MICHAEL CRUZ WELL WE'RE
NOT TO BE CURRENT IT WAS A
RELIEF TO HAVE THEM- WHAT'S
THAT- THE BILL REALLY IS
ANOTHER IMPORTANT TOOL TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY ON THE BOOKS.
AND AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CHAIR OFCOMMITTEE HOUSING AND
GOVERNMENT FINANCE THEIR STAFF.
AND WE MET ALONG WITH THE
AUTHOR BECAUSE HE WORKED ON THE
ISSUE. OF WEEKLY ARTICLES- ALL.
RIGHT. AFTER I BELIEVE
SOMETIMES THANK YOU. OKAY THANK-
GOING TO ASK IF THERE'S A IN
THE WHO. TO IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IF SO STEP FORWARD PLEASE
SEE NONE WILL CHECK YOUR FULL
ROOM. ENCINO IN THERE WILL GO
TO THE MODERATOR AND ASK. ASK
HIM TO LEASE QUEUE UP. ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE OF TOLL CONFERENCE
LINE AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE.
HEARING THE TOTAL NUMBER THAT
YOU SEE IN THE QUEUE YEAH WE
WOULD REMIND EVERYONE THAT AT
THE OUTSET OF THIS MEETING
REGARDLESS OF THE SUBJECT
MATTER OR THE BILL WE
ESTABLISHED A MAXIMUM OF TEN
MINUTES FOR SUPPORT. IN TEN
MINUTES FOR OPPOSITION M. S.
CONSOLE AND THE POLICE ARE- BE
MINDFUL THAT AND TO LET ME KNOW
IF WORK CD NOTED ANY POINT-
THIS IS FOR. NAME AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT ONLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A. B. NINE EIGHTY NINE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONCE
AGAIN THOSE INSTRUCTIONS ARE
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
PLEASE. THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. OKAY WE WILL COME BACK TO
OPPOSITION AT AT THIS POINT AND
WE DO HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IDENTIFIED ON THIS
BILL BRIAN A GUSTO AND ALO
LOOSE MARATHI- BRIAN IF YOU ARE
ON THE COAST PHONE LINE YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRYING TO GOT- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT AND
ALSO SHARING. THE CONCERNS OF
OUR COLLEAGUES AT WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY- WE
ARE WE'RE GET REGRETFULLY AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL AND WHILE WE'VE HAD
THIS. VERY THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
AND YET ARE CONCERNED THEIR
MAIN RESOLVED- NOTWITHSTANDING
TODAY PROPOSED AMENDMENT THAT I
WANT TO MAKE. TWO POINTS- IN
THAT REGARD THE FIRST IS THAT
REQUIRING EXHAUSTION WE BELIEVE
THIS NEW ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS
IN OTHER WORDS MANDATING THAT
THE DEVELOPER GO TO THIS NEW
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS.
DIMINISHES THE ENFORCEABILITY
OF THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT AND I. BELIEVE THAT IS WHY
THE ANALYSIS NOTES A NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
GROUPS WHO HAD BEEN IN SUPPORT
OF GONE TO NEUTRAL THE SECOND
POINT. THAT ONE ELABORATE ON IN
A MOMENT IS THAT OUR CLIENTS.
AND OTHERS WITH STANDING TO
ENFORCE THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT YOU AREN'T
SUBJECT TO ADD EXHAUSTED
REQUIREMENT. FOR THOSE OF US
pBIFURCATED PROCESS INJECTS
UNCERTAINTY AND POTENTIAL DELAY
THAT WILL MAKE IT HARDER ON
THAT FIRST POINT I JUST WANT
TO. KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
STRENGTHS OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT IS THAT THE
MERE THREAT OF LITIGATION OFTEN
SUCCESSFULLY ENSURES COMPLIANCE
WE- WE TALK ABOUT. HOW WE DON'T
SEE MUCH LITIGATION- HOW OTHER
ALLEGATIONS JUDGMENT ABOUT THE
REALITY OF. THE THREAT OF
LITIGATION. OFTEN RESOLVES THE
ISSUE REPORTED TO GO TO COURT
AND SO WE REMAIN CONCERNED A
MANDATE THAT DEVELOPERS USE
THIS SEMESTER PROCESS. PUTS
GIVING THEM A CHOICE. DOCTORS
ARE GOING DIRECTLY TO COURT
REMOVES AN ERA FROM THAT
QUIVERED MAKES LITIGATION
ACCORDING PORTS ARE MORE
DISTANT THREATS AND THEREFORE
IN A LESS OMINOUS ONE AND
THEREFORE REDUCING THE ABILITY
OF DEVELOPERS TO PERHAPS COULD-
COMPLYING SHORT OF ANY.
LITIGATION FOR OUR CLIENT BUT
NOT SECOND POINT BIG DIFFERENT
CREASING WE COMPLICATED OUR
CRICKET LITIGATION PROCESS
THAT'S PROPOSED- WE DON'T THINK
WHICH I DON'T THINK IT'S BY THE PROPOSED
DEMANDS. IS THAT DEEPLY
CONCERNING FOR US THIS IS A
FAIRLY UNUSUAL PROCESSES
PROPOSE WERE. POSSIBLY
UNPRECEDENTED WHERE SOME
PARTIES MUST EXHAUST REPORTED
BEEN STRAIGHT UP BODIES THAT
OFFER. AND OTHERS LIKE OUR
CLIENTS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
GROUPS TO GO DIRECTLY TO COURT.
CREATING A POSSIBILITY NOW OF
DOING LITIGATION I THINK MANY
OF YOU CAN ANTICIPATE THE WAYS
IN WHICH THAT MIGHT PLAY OUT TO
MAKE ENFORCEMENT MORE.
DIFFICULT- WE IF. BY FILE PIZZA
WITH A WORK THAT YOU'RE GONNA
SEVERAL IN THE H. EIGHTEEN ONE
OF THEM SEVERAL SAY WE THOUGHT
GOTTEN DEVELOPER FILED
DEVELOPER MR IS NINETY NINE
BODY BUT WE ONLY HAVE NINETY
DAYS UNDER THE APPLICABLE
DOCUMENTATION TO GET ALL OF OUR
CLAIMS FILED SO WE CAN'T WAIT
THE RESOLUTION THAT PROCESS.
I'M NOT NOW WHAT'S LIKE TO BE
THE REAL OF THAT WORK HELLO
GOVERNMENT THAT'S NOW BOTH
PRECEDING ARE GOING TO SEEK A
STAY OF THE COURT PROCEEDINGS
ARE NOW OUR CASES SIMPLY
TRADING TODAY. INCLUDING
UNCERTAINTY AND DELAY. AND THEN
THE BILL SAYS THAT THE DECISION
OF THE BODY BECOMES ACTION OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND NOW
YOU'VE- GOT AN- ADMINISTRATIVE
BODY RENDERING AN OPINION THAT-
DECISION STEPS INTO THE SHOES
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT. UNITS
STREAM IN OUR LITIGATION. SO
NOW WE'RE NOT ATTACKING THE
LOCAL. GOVERNMENT PROCESS ARE
TALKING. ATTACKING THE OUTCOME
OF THE- APPEAL PROCESS WHICH WE
WERE NOT AND ARE NOT THERE TO
HELP BUILD THE RECORD WE CANNOT
PRESENT EVIDENCE SO. THESE ARE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE. WITH THIS.
INJECTS MORE UNCERTAINTY. AND
POTENTIALLY REDUCES THE ABILITY
TO ENFORCE PRODUCTION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
CLIENTS WE SHARED THESE
CONCERNS WITH THE AUTHOR. YOU
KNOW THIS IS GOING TO BE AN
ONGOING CONVERSATION BUT TODAY
WE REMAIN A PART OF THE LAST
MINUTE UNTIL WE CAN RESOLVE.
THIS BY THIS SIGNIFICANT
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS WITH THIS
SOMEWHAT. NOVEL PROCESS SO FOR
ALL THOSE REASONS- WE REMAIN A
PERSON CAN SHARE. THIRD WITH
CREW TO. IN THE MR. FOR ON THE
LINE AND POLICE UP BY THE
MINUTE LIMIT PER. OPPOSITE
SPEAKER AND IN FAIRNESS TO THE
SPORTS SPEAKERS WHO ALREADY
SPOKEN. TO OTHERS WHO WERE
TESTIFYING OF THE BILLS TODAY
THANK YOU. AT TWO MINUTES I
WILL WILL DO MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU. FOR THE OPPORTUNITYTO
SPEAK TODAY MY NAME IS LOUIS
MONTANA. I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF. THE CALIFORNIA BEAT. THAT
PERSON IN THAT THANK AUTHOR AND
ALL THE PARTIES WORKING ON THIS
BILL AFTER THEIR DILIGENT
EFFORT IN RESOLVING. SOME OF
THE REALLY CONCERNING
AMENDMENTS COMING OUT OF THE
CITY GOVERNMENT THE FINANCE
COMMITTEE IN THAT THEY ALL.
ACCOMPANIED THE ADOPTED A POSE
MUCH AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL AFTER ABOUT HEARING. ABOUT
THE MOMENT TODAY INTO GO MOST
OF THE WAY IN ATTRACTING ALL OF
OUR CONCERNS. SO I WILL NOT ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON EIGHTY NINE
EIGHTY NINE TODAY. BUT IF YOU
WANT TO GO OVER SOME OF MY
CONCERNS AND REALLY EXPRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF. ADDRESSING THEM
IN THIS PROCESS THAT. I MISSED
REQUIRED MR GABRIEL. LAID OUT-
IN THEIR COMMENTS EARLIER- I
LIED ALL OF MY CAR. ACTUALLY I
THE IF YOU- THE PIPER PROCEED-
CONCERN. I THE TARGET ATTACK-
OUTSTANDING- INTO THE OFFICE.
GETTING UNDER THE ACA- THAT MR
AUGUSTA MENTIONED IN HIS REGARD
SO I WILL NOT GO OVER THAT- I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT. IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. TO GET THIS
LAST FEATURE RIGHT. A
CALIFORNIA B. WORKS WITH A LOT
OF GIVE ME ORDERS AROUND THE
STATE. WHO SUE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO ARE VIOLATING
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS. ON
HOUSING- ON THEIR OWN. NOT ON
THE DEVELOPERS. AND THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IT CAN OUR BE
VERY CHALLENGING FOR DEVELOPERS
TO SEE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS-
BECAUSE THEY'RE OFTEN REPEAT
PLAYERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND SO MANY OF THEM FEEL VERY
CHILLED ACTED IN THERE RIGHT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE GETTING IT
RIGHT. UP WITH THIRD PARTIES
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
BILL SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY MAKING SURE THAT
WE- DO AND THAT PLAN CORRECTLY-
I THOUGHT MAYBE ONE THE LACK.
OF POINT OF MAKE HERE IS THAT
REQUIRING AN APPLICANT HE USED
THE OFFICE REALLY RIPS THE
LAYING A FINAL RESOLUTION AND
MAKING IT HARDER IN MANY CASES
THE POSSIBLE. RIPPLES PURSING
MOBILE RIGHT UNDER OUR NORMAL
LIVES. I COULD PLUG IT COULD
NOT HAVE. BARRED THE OPPOSITE
BU YOU HAVE THE STANDING UNDER
THE HSA- I PERSONALLY THINK
IT'S A IT'S PROBABLY A MUCH
STEEPER APPROACH TO ESTABLISH
THAT. OFFICE AND THEN REQUIRE
ENFORCEMENT GIVING THE OFFICE
FIND OUT ABOUT THE PEOPLE
ACTED. OTHERWISE WE RISK
INTENTIONALLY. BUT NO IMPORT AJ
CLAIMS FOR RELEVANT. AFTER YOU
KNOW YOU'RE MONTHS AT THE
OFFICE CREATED- THEY THAT YOU
KNOW THAT- THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT NOT MOVING THE
BILL FORWARD IF WE'RE REALLY
NOT ABLE TO LAND THE PLANE- IT
AND YOU KNOW IF ALL THE
INTRICATE LEGISLATORS ARE ARE
NOT ABLE TO COME TO AGREEMENT
THEY GIVE ME THE NECESSARY
CONFIDENCE COULD BE HERE TODAY
AND NOT URGING A NO VOTE I YOU
KNOW LIKE I SAID REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT EVERY. ONE OF THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS WHO
SPOKE TODAY AND PUT INTO THE
ALONG WITH THEIR STAFF MAKE
SURE THAT THE BILL IS REALLY.
MOVE ARE GREAT FUN WITH ALL THE
HELP WHEN YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY
IN THE PERSON THAT- I THINK
THERE'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
HIRING OUT TO DO I THINK THAT
ALREADY OUT. CAN BE DONE IN
TIME. OR REDUCE THE THREAT OF
WAR AND I REALLY THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY-
AND I REALLY REALLY WANT TO.
URGE ALL THE FOLKS WHO ARE
WORKING ON A BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE. LANDING THE PLANE
CORRECTLY. ON ON ON ON NOT.
ELIMINATOR THE AJ'S. THE H. A.
BRILLIANT. COMPORT HOW THEY LOG.
HAS IMPORT THING AND RESULTING-
THE PROPERTY. THANKS THANK YOU
BUT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
GALLERY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS AN
OPPOSITION POSITION TO A. B.
NINE EIGHTY NINE. I'VE SEEN
NONE WE'LL CHECK- THE OVAL ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO TESTIFY
ONCE A MODERATOR. TO CHECK TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE. IN THE
QUEUE. TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB NINE EIGHTY NINE. THANK
YOU COULD LIKE TO STATE
OPPOSITION TO EIGHTEEN NINETY
NINE WHEN YOU PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE THREE LINES IN Q. WE'LL
GO FIRST TO LINE ONE FIFTY TWO.
MR KERR MEMBERS YOU CAN RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE TO LEAVE CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
BUT WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
MEASURE AS DRAFTED- WE HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE TO DIGEST THE
ENTIRETY OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. HOWEVER IT FIRST
GLANCE WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS FROM OUR
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR OR THE OTHER
CENTERS- ON THOSE AMENDMENTS-
BUT AS OF RIGHT. NOW SIR WE
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS LEE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
WANT TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES CURRENTLY
OPPOSED BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS. ONE
TWELVE. GLOBAL CALIFORNIA THIS
IS RECALL AND WE OPPOSE. NINETY
EIGHTY NINE. THANK YOU ONE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN IF YOU'D STILL LIKE
TO SHARE YOUR OPPOSITION WILL
YOU PLEASE REPEAT ONE AND THEN
ZERO. TURN OFF FOR THE LINE TO
GET THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR-
WE'RE GONNA COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE KNOWS COMMITTEES
OPPORTUNITY- TO- COMMENT
EXPRESSING CONCERNS- THAT WE
HAVE FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEMINAL. RECOGNIZE SENATOR
BATES FIRST FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
OF TROUBLED. THANK YOU I TERRON
COURTESY ON. THE ANALYSIS THAT
I'VE BEEN READING ON REALLY
RAISES ISSUES THAT ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL IN TERMS OF WHAT
SO THIS PARTICULAR. APPOINTED A
BODY- COULD DO IN TERMS OF OVER
RIDING OUT THE LOCAL LAND USE
AUTHORITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FIGHT FOR CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE
THAT I THINK NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. GOING FORWARD WHICH
FOR ME TODAY I WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THE BILL THE OTHER
THING I'D LIKE TO MENTION IS
THAT THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT OUT THIS IS IN DEFENSE OF
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT. DOES NOT
PROVIDE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
DICTATE AT LEAST A PERCENTAGE
OF THESE LARGE DEVELOPMENT FILE
WOULD BE FOR SALE. A LOT OF-
THE INPUT I'VE RECEIVED IS THAT
MANY OF THE ONES THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED ARE LARGE- APARTMENT
COMPLEXES THAT'S VERY GOOD I'M
NOT SAYING THAT THAT ISN'T A
GREAT STARTING POINT BUT WE'VE
HEARD A LOT IN OUR- A
LEGISLATOR. LEGISLATURE TODAY
AN INFECTION OVER THE YEARS
THAT ALLOWING PEOPLE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUY HOMES
PROVIDES THAT INTERGENERATIONAL
WEALTH GROWTH WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
POVERTY. SO I THINKTHERE'S
SOMETHING WITH THE HHA THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT THAT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT ALSO AS
WE GO FORWARD AND I JUST PUT
THAT ON THE RECORD BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I HEAR. FROM YOU
KNOW MY FOLKS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT SAY WE WANT OUR
HOUSE AND WE WANT TO MEET ARENA
BUT WE WANT TO HAVE SOME
AUTHORITY TO. DEVELOP A PLANNED
COMMUNITY PLAN WHICH WAS THE
FOUNDATION FRANKLY OF WHAT
DEVELOPED IN ORANGE COUNTY I IN
THE SEVENTIES EIGHTIES AND
NINETIES. THAT YOU HAD ON THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR RENTAL STARTING
OUT AND MOVING TO SOMETHING ON
A CONDO AND ON UP THE LADDER.
IN THOSE ARE IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT HAVE BANNED ALL PART OF
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM- CERTAINLY
AS LONG AS YOU KNOW MY PARENTS
HAVE LIVED HERE AND CERTAINLY
THE OPPORTUNITY IT PROVIDED.
MANY OF US WHO ARE HERE SO- I
THINK THE CONSTITUTIONAL.
ISSUES BACK TO THAT REALLY NEED
TO BE VETTED. BEFORE WE TAKE
THE STAFF ON A PRE SOMETHING.
THAT HAVE PAID FOR GOOD BASE
NOT NOT SAYING THAT WHAT SONDER
ATTEMPTING TO DO HERE FOR THE
BAD ACTORS SHOULDN'T BE
CONSIDERED. BUT THERE'S A LOT
OF OTHER THINGS THAT NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED BEFORE WE TAKE STEPS
LIKE THE F. R. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU- JUST SUGGESTS THE
AUTHOR YOU CAN DO IT. ON
COMMENTS YOU MAY JUST INCLUDE
YOUR OWN COMMENTS SAID DURING
YOUR CLOTHES IF YOU SO DESIRE-
THE MEAT- MOVED TO CENTER-
CHILL BOTH. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN THE
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY NINE
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND
SOME OF THE SUPPORTERS FOR
CONNECTING WITH ME AND MY
OFFICE THIS MORNING. THERE HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF CHANGES IN THIS
BILL IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
FROM WHAT WE'VE HEARD IN THE
TESTIMONY SO FAR THERE ALSO
GROUPS IN THE MID TO CHANGING
THEIR POSITIONS. BEFORE I GET
MY FINAL VOTE ON THIS BILL I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT IN ITS
FINAL FORM IN PRINT. AND WHILE
I APPRECIATE WHAT THE INDUSTRY
IS TRYING TO DO I REALLY DO.
AND THERE ARE CONCERNS FROM A
DISTRICT THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE ADDRESSED FIRST. THEREFORE
I WILL BE ASSISTING IN THIS
MEASURE TODAY BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEE IN THE FUTURE.
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
BOGAN OTHER MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZED IN A WAY BECAUSE
KIM- MISTER CHAIR I WILL MOVE
THE BILL- AND- YOU KNOW A LOT
OF PEOPLE COMPLAIN WHEN.
MEASURES ARE TRIPLE REFERRED.
AND I THINK-AB NINE EIGHT NINE
SHOWS THE VALUE OF HAVING-
THREE. COMPETING ODDS
COMMITTEE'S. REVIEW IT BECAUSE
THE REMAINING ISSUES THAT ARE
AT LEAST. OUTLINED HAD THAT
THAT WE GOT. ALL PERTAIN TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND I KNOW
THAT. THE CHAIRS HERE AND IS
FOLLOWING THE CONVERSATION.
THAT'S GOING ON- I'M- YOU KNOW
I DID ALL THE POINTS YOU RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION WESTERN
CENTERED ON. THE PROCESS AND-
THERE'S SORT OF. I STILL DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY. WHY DEVELOPER
WOULD CHOOSE THE- ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS STANDARD VERSUS THE
NOVO ON APPEAL BUT THAT'S NOT
FOR ME TO DECIDE. BUT IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN. A EXCELL M. IN
IMPORTANT WORK TO BE DONE- I
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH ALL THREE
CHEERS WITH THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIR. WHO
UNFORTUNATELY HASN'T BEEN IN ON
THE CONVERSATIONS THIS IS. HIS
PING PONG BETWEEN HOUSING AND
GOVERNANCE. AND AGAIN SOMETIMES
THE THORNIER. CHALLENGE IS THE
PROCESS IS TO GO ON VERSES.
THIS S LOCAL GOVERNMENT THIS
IS HOUSING. IT'S HOW DO WE GET
HOW DO WE CREATE THAT PATHWAY
SO WITH THAT. YOU HAVE A
COMMOTION ARNOLD. GOOD LUCK TO
THE THREE CHAIRS AND THE
AUTHOR. VERY GOOD THANK YOU-
BEFORE WE- REMOVE THE ITEM OF
FORMALLY WILL GO TO A. COMMENTS
BY THE CENTER CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU. MR SO- TYPE. THAT D.
D. PROPONENTS AND THE AUTHOR OR
TRYING TO CREATE A PATHWAY.
THAT WOULD RESPECT THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND YET
ALLOW FOR YOU KNOW SOME
ENTITIES BASED SPECIFICALLY ON
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOLKS
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS TO NOT
HAVE TO GO TO THE EXPENSE OF
GOING TO COURT. AND- THE ONLY
ISSUE IS THAT THE VARIOUS
ENFORCEMENT ASPECTS OF THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
REALLY CAN ONLY BE FULLY
ACHIEVED IN COURT YES CERTAINLY
YES WE WANT TO AVOID GOING TO
COURT IT'S REALLY TRYING TO BE
THE STICK THE ULTIMATE STICK
AND YOU KNOW YOU DON'T REALLY
WANT TO BUT I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT IN NO WAY THIS EFFORT
UNDERMINES THE ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITIES OF THE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT SO I
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS I
THINK THEY'RE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I KNOW THAT
THEY ARE NOT YET FULLY AGREED
UPON. SO DOES ME GIVE ME A
LITTLE PAUSE- BUT I'M WILLING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND IT-
WITH THAT SENSE OF TRUST THAT
THESE WILL BE LANDED AND THE
ENFORCEMENT POWERS OF THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
WOULD BE RESPECTED- SO- I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. THE
TICKET CENTER AT ANYONE ELSE ON
ON THE FLOOR A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE WAS TO BE RECOGNIZED.
ON THE BILL. THE CENTER NUMBER
THANK YOU I'M SORRY THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN CDS PLEASE WHAT
WHAT'S THAT A WHITE HOUSE HE
SAID THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE-
WISH TO. JUMP INTO THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU- AND
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE AUTHOR
AND I KNOW THERE WERE A NUMBER
OF COMMENTS THERE- HIT YOUR
CLOTHES YOU FEEL FREE TO DO IT
HOWEVER YOU WISH IF YOU WANNA
RESPOND TO COMMENTS QUESTION IT
THANK YOU YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAN FIRSTLY THANK ALL
THE SENATORS FOR THEIR FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS IF I
JUST MIGHT. ADDRESS A FEW OF
THEM JUST I WILL SAY AND THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES FOR SHARING
YOUR YOUR CONCERNS LITTLE BIT
SURPRISED TO HEAR THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE NOT HAD ANYTHING
FLAG FOR US BY LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL AND WE'RE PRETTY
CLEARLY DRAWING WITHIN THE
LINES ON THIS ONE IN TERMS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE AND SO
YOU KNOW HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN ANY
SPECIFIC CONCERNS BUT FOR THE
MOST PART. I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
SQUARELY IN LINE WITH WHAT
HAPPENS IN A LOT OF SITUATIONS
ND CERTAINLY ALSO I APPRECIATE
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT
HOMEOWNERSHIP WHICH IS SAY THAT
THE HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT
REQUIRES HE APPLIES EQUALLY TO
DEVELOPMENTS THAT ARE BUILT FOR
OWNERSHIP SO THIS IS ALSO.
HOPEFULLY SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING TO HELP. MORE PEOPLE.
THAT AND THAT THE WEALTH
CREATION THAT YOU MENTIONED SO.
SO HOPING TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY HAVE A CONVERSATION
PERHAPS IF WE GET OUT TODAY ON
YOUR PHOTO- YOUR PHONE AT A
LATER STAGE IN THE PROCESS. I'M
JUST ALSO WANT TO SAY IN
RESPONSE TO A- TURQUOISE
SENATOR SKINNER. AND WE
COMPLETELY SHARE YOUR CONCERNS
IN PERSPECTIVE HERE AND THE
LAST THING WE WANT TO DO IS
UNDERMINE. THE REALLY GOOD WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE WITH AND
OTHERS HAVE DONE WITH THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT THE
PURPOSE HERE. IS TO STRENGTHEN
THAT. I WOULD JUST SAY FOR THE
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE
COMMITTEE. PART OF WHAT.
ATTRACTED US TO THIS APPROACH
IS THAT IT IS TWO THINGS ONE-
THAT WAS BROUGHT TO US BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
WHICH WE THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED. FOR ADVICE ABOUT HOW
TO STRENGTHEN. THE BUILT UP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY HEARD- IN
INTERVIEWS AND CONVERSATIONS
WITH FOLKS IN THE SPACE AS THEY
WENT AROUND THE STATE. AND TALK
TO PEOPLE. AND THE OTHER THING
THAT GIVES ME CONFIDENCE ABOUT
THIS APPROACH IS THAT. AS WAS
MENTIONED IT'S BEEN IN PLACE IN
MASSACHUSETTS FOR SEVERAL
DECADES NOW. THERE'S RESEARCH
THAT WAS DONE BY MIT. WHERE
THEY LOOKED AT THIS AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE VERY
CONCLUSIVELY. THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING AN APPROACH LIKE THIS
THE BENEFITS OF HAVING AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AND HOW
THAT ACTUALLY. WAS ABLE TO HELP
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD. AND WHAT
CAUGHT MY EYE IN A
PARTICULARLY. WAS THE NUMBER OF
CASES THAT ULTIMATELY SETTLED-
DEBT THAT THIS PROCESS SECTION
COURAGE EIGHTY PLUS PERCENT
CASES TO GET TO SETTLEMENT VERY
QUICKLY SO IT'S ACTUALLY A WAY.
TO HELP PEOPLE TO GET TO YES TO
RESOLVE DISPUTES BETWEEN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOLKS. AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHICH I
ACTUALLY THINK WOULD BE. A VERY
POSITIVE THING GIVEN. GIVEN THE
MIXED IN THE DEPTHS OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS RAN SO I WOULD
JUST SAY. IN CONCLUSION. THANK
YOU TO YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIRS. OF ALL
THREE COMMITTEES FOR. NOT FOR
INDULGING US FOR THEIR FOR
THEIR STAFF FOR THE- TREMENDOUS
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. REALLY
APPRECIATE. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FIND A PATHWAY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION. I AM I AM.
SOMEWHAT OF AN ETERNAL OPTIMIST
BUT I ACTUALLY THINK. THERE'S A
VERY CLEAR PATH FORWARD FOR US
IN SEVERAL WAYS FOR US TO GET
TO A PLACE WHERE. I HOPE THIS
BILL WILL WORK WELL FOR
EVERYBODY AND SO WITH THAT-
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND
I BOTH. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION.
OKAY WELL THANK VERY MUCH MAY
BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T- EXPRESS-
SENATOR WIENER SAID THANKS FOR
WORKING WITH HIM- AS WELL AS
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE BILL- HE
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY BUT-
IT'S- REALLY THE STENCH OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT HAS BEEN. TAKING
THE LEAD HERE SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. WE HAVE A MOTION I
BELIEVE BY SENATOR WHAT KOWSKI
THAT'S BEEN CONFIRMED. ALAS
CONSOLE NICOLE ROLE PLEASE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
EIGHT NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CORTEZ E. NIGHT ORTEZ
THE I'D SAY IT'S NOT LETTING.
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT BY ADMIN
EGGMAN I REQUIRE A CHORE BOOK.
THE CHILDREN NOT TURNING
SCANNER. SCANNER I REMEMBER.
NUMBER NOT VOTING WITH CASKEY
CASKEY I. FIVE TWO ZERO. WILL
BE FIVE TO ZERO KEEP THE ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBER.
THANK YOU. RIGHT WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE AND FOLLOW ORDERS-
SOME MEMBER BRYANT WOULD BE
NEXT WITH THE B. ONE ZERO FOUR
THREE TEN FORTY THREE I BELIEVE
IS THE NUMBER ON THAT BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME IN THE
END YOU MAY PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU SENATOR
I THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MAYBE TEN FORTY THREE
WILL ADD ADDITIONAL INCOME
CATEGORY STATE HOUSING LAW
COMPRISED OF INDIVIDUALS LIVING
BELOW THE FIFTEEN PERCENT. OF
THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME. THE
HOUSING PROGRAMS RELY ON THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE TO
DEFINE INCOME CATEGORIES TO
PROVIDE FORMULAS FOR
CALCULATING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COSTS. CURRENT LAW DEFINES FOUR
INCOME CATEGORIES WITH THE
LOWEST CATEGORY COMPRISING OF
INDIVIDUALS LIVING BELOW THE
30% OF AN AREA'S MEDIAN INCOME.
HOWEVER THE GREAT DISPARITY
BETWEEN HOUSEHOLD GROUP
TOGETHER IN THIS CATEGORY FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
ANNUAL INCOME FOR A HOUSEHOLD
OF FOUR IN THIS CATEGORY WAS
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND. EIGHT
HUNDRED HOWEVER HOUSEHOLDS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ON
THE BRINK OF EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS REPORTED INCOMES
OF LESS THAN SEVENTEEN.
THOUSAND DOLLARS. A RECENT
REPORT BY THE LA COUNTY WHICH
INCLUDED AN ADDITIONAL CATEGORY
TO CAPTURE THEIR MOST LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS INDIATED THAT
ABOUT TEN PERCENT. OF THE LA
COUNTY RENTERS LIVE BELOW THE
15% OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
OUT OF THESE HOUSEHOLD ALMOST
90% FOR MORE THAN 50% OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSING TALKS. BABY
TEN FORTY THREE ADDRESSES THIS
GAP IN STATE HOUSING POLICY. BY
STAFF WISHING AN ACUTELY LOW
INCOME CATEGORY. AND A FORMULA
TO CALCULATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COSTS FOR THIS GROUP. THIS NEW
CATEGORY WOULD BE MADE UP OF
INDIVIDUALS LIVING OUT OF BELOW
15% OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
I WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
HOUSING FOR INDIVIDUALS. FOR
CLOSE TO FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS. BRING ME TODAY
I'M JOINED BY LAKE COUNTY'S
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
REGIONAL PLANNING ANY BOAT AT.
VERY THANK YOU SO MEMBER AMY
BORDER. IF YOU WERE ON THE
PHONE LINE YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON AS ASSEMBLYMAN BRIAN
SAID MY NAME IS AMY BOWED ACT.
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
REGIONAL PLANNING FOR THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. I AM
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE LA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. I
WANT TO FIRST ST I SIMPLY
NUMBER BRIAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC ENTER
THE CONSULTANTS FOR WORKING
WITH US ON MICHELLE. H. AS
STATED AT TEN FORTY THREE WHAT
A MAN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE TO DEFINE A NEW INCOME
CATEGORIES FOR CALCULATING.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COSTS. THE
EX. LOW INCOME LEVEL. IT'S NEW
DEFINITION WOULD BE COMPRISED
OF FAMILIES LIVING WITHIN THE
ZERO TO FIFTEEN PERCENT. OF THE
AREA MEDIAN INCOME BRACKETS.
YOU MIGHT THINK THAT. IT WOULD
NOT BE AN ISSUE FOR THESE FOLKS
TO BE IN THERE THE- EXISTING
VERY LOW INCOME CATEGORY. BUT
IN FACT WE DO NEED A SEPARATION
BETWEEN THESE ACUTELY LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND ARE VERY
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES. IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
OF ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT. EACH
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO FORMULA
AND THEY COULDN'T IN THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE TO CALCULATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING COSTS. FOR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH INCOMES OF LESS
THAN 30% A. M. I. E. AS THAT'S
CALLED- EXTREMELY LOW INCOME. I
ALSO MENTIONED IT IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE COUNTY HAS ISSUED
AN ANNUAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
MS OUR RECORDS FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY PREPARED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
CORPORATION. THE ANALYSIS
ACTUALLY INCLUDED IN THE A.
ALLY CATEGORY DEFINED AS 00215%
A. M. A. M. HI N. AS RICH AS
JUST STATED THE MOST RECENTLY
RECORDED. INFORMATION FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN SHOWS THAT 10%
OF RENTER HOUSEHOLDS FALL
WITHIN THE 15% AMR. WORKING
EARLY OF THE HOUSEHOLD 69%
IDENTIFY AS PEOPLE OF COLOR.
AMENDING THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FOR THE STATE TO
REQUIRE SENATE B UNITS BE
PROVIDED AT THIS SPECIFIC
INCOME LEVEL OR REQUIRE THAT
REPLACEMENT UNITS BE MADE
AVAILABLE. ACTUALLY A SIMPLE
AMENDMENT TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE THAT WOULD HAVE FAR
REACHING POSITIVE BENEFITS IN
STABILIZING HOUSING OPTIONS FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION
SHRANK SHORT LA COUNTY SUPPORTS
THIS BILL WHEN ASKED FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. AND I YIELD
THE REMAINDER OF MY TERM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO THE GALLERY AND ASK THERE'S
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO EXPRESS
ITS SUPPORT POSITION ON A. B.
TEN FORTY THREE AT THIS TIME-
YES WE HAVE A SPEAKER PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND- YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
F. MARKS THE AVERAGE FOR THE
JUST CITED CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
WISH SO TOO DO THE SAME. THE
SINGING NUN WILL CHECK YOUR
FULL ROOM. AND THERE'S NO ONE
THERE WISHING TO TESTIFY SO
WE'LL COVER MODERATOR
MODERATOR- BELESKEY TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP- IN THIS CASE SUPPORT
TESTIMONY ON A. B. TEN FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE B.
TEN FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU MY NUMBER IT'S UNCLEAR
MY NUMBER TO CALL TO OPEN YOUR
MIND. WE'LL GO NOW TO LINE.
NUMBER SEVENTY NINE IT'S GOING
TO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BIRTH ON YELLOW ALERT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT.
THANK YOU LINE. ONE SIXTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS
TINA RESULTS WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN THE CUBAN SUPPORT PRESS
ONE ZERO LEAD TO LINE ONE FIFTY
THREE ONE FIVE THREE POINTERS.
HELLO THIS IS AMBERLEY LESLIE
WITH HOUSING CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
STRUCTURE OF A CONCLUDES THE Q.
M. OLD NO WAR OPPOSITIONAL
COMMENTERS IN Q. THE US WAS OUR
SUPPORT COMMENTS AS I
UNDERSTOOD IT AND WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION NOW WE DO NOT HAVE
AN IDENTIFIED LEAD OPPOSITION.
WITNESS LAST THERE'S ANYONE THE
GALLERY WHO WISHES TO TAKE IN
OPPOSE POSITION ON THIS BILL
SEEING NONE BUT WILL CHECK OVER
FULL THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO
TESTIFY. A MODERATOR BACK TO A
BE A TEN FORTY THREE THIS TIME
IN OPPOSITION WOULD APPRECIATE
IF YOU QUEUE UP ANY. WITNESSES
THANK YOU MR CHAIR TO COME OUT
IN OPPOSITION OF THE MEAT AND
POULTRY PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN FOR COMMENT ABOUT
POLLUTION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. THE STRUCTURE WE HAD NO
RESPONSE FOR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU FOR CHECKING A WIN FROM
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND ASKED IF ANYONE
WISHES TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL AB
TEN FORTY THREE AT THIS TIME A
SENATOR SKINNER'S CENTER
PROBABLY EURO- I UNDERSTAND
SENATOR SKINNER HAS. THE FREE
WE'RE GONNA DO THE SAME THING
MOVE A BILL TYSON. YOU KNOW- HE
WIN THE COIN TOSS. NO MOVING
THE BILL I UNDERSTAND OKAY- ANY
OTHER COMMENTS- ON THIS BILL
ALL. IT IS THIS MY FIRST TIME
ON THIS CAR FOR MY FIRST TIME
BEFORE THIS BODY- I'M ON IT I'M
GRATEFUL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR APPLE- OKAY- IN WITH
THE MOTION JUST TO CONFIRM IS
BY SENATOR SKINNER MUST CONSULT
A COLD ROLLED THIS TIME. THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
E. CORTEZ HE I'D BATES. BATES
HI COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT BY
EGGMAN EGGMAN I AM ACQUIRE. A
CHILL BOTH. A TROUBLED EYES
SKINNER. SKINNER HI AMBER.
NUMBER FIVE WITH SKI WITH HUSKY
I EIGHT ZERO. READ ZERO IN THE
BILL STAY ON CALL FOR THE
OFFICE OF MEMBER THANK YOU. THE
NEXT BILL IS A B. TWELVE TWENTY
THE AUTHORS WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
READ US. IN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COME FORWARD AT THIS TIME. WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO HEAR YOUR
PRESENTATION. I KNOW GO. GOOD
AFTERNOON FEEL FREE TO PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT A B. TWELVE TWENTY LAST
SESSION I AUTHORED AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE WHICH WAS AN ATTEMPT
TO DEVELOP A CALM COME
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY SOLUTION
FOR THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS.
AB TWELVE TWENTY IN THE FORM
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A RESULT OF
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
RESTRUCTURING CHANGES SO WE CAN
ENSURE WE ARE PROVIDING GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT TO
HELP THE STATE IS COMBATING
HOMELESSNESS. AB TWELVE TWENTY
MAKES A NUMBER OF STRUCTURAL
CHANGES TO THE CURRET HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL THIS MEASURE RENAMES
THE HOMELESS COUNSEL TO THE
CALIFORNIA INTER. COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS. THIS NAME CHANGE
MORE ACCURATELY REPRESENTS THE
PURPOSE OF THE COUNCIL AND
WE'LL SET THE STAGE FOR THE
RESTRUCTURING OF THE COUNCIL
MEMBERSHIP AND COMMITTEES.
MEMBERSHIP WILL CONSIST OF
DIRECTORS AND SECRETARIES OF
THE STATE. INDIVIDUALS WITH
LIVED HOMELESSNESS EXPERIENCE
INCLUDING UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH
UNDER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
IN MARCH THE HOMELESS COUNCIL
ADOPTED ITS FIRST EVER ACTION
PLAN FOR PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE STATE THE
ACTION PLAN PROVIDES THE
DETAILS ON HOW THE HOMELESS
COUNCIL WILL ACHIEVE ITS GOALS.
THE ACTION PLAN COMES AT A
CRITICAL TIME AS THE BIDEN
HARRIS ADMINISTRATION IS
BEGINNING TO FOCUS ON THE ISSUE
OF HOMELESSNESS THE STATE MUST
ENSURE PROPER AND EFFICIENT
COORDINATION AMONG STATE
AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND OTHER
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS. OTHER
STATES IN THE COUNTRY HAVE
SIMILAR COUNCIL STRUCTURES SO
THIS IS A STANDARD MODEL. THIS
LEGISLATOR HAS DEDICATED
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS WHILE STATE
FUNDING PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING ALONE WILL
NOT SOLVE SYSTEMIC ISSUES. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THE COUNCIL IS
COMPRISED OF STATE LEADERS AND
DEPARTMENT HEADS WHO ARE BEST
EQUIPPED TO EFFECTIVELY
COORDINATED. COORDINATE AND
RESPOND TO HOMELESSNESS. TODAY
I HAVE WITH ME LOUIS MERON T.
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA YIMBY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. OKAY
THANK YOU MISS MARTINEZ PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. I THINK
IT SHARE A LITTLE SMARTER WITH
CALIFORNIAN B. HERE IN SPORT-
MAYBE THE TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT.
IN GENERAL AND THE STATE NEEDS
A MORE STREAMLINED BOB DOLE AND
CONSISTENT APPROACH TO
RESOLVING WHAT VOTERS ARE GUARD
AT THE GATE MOST IMPORTANT
PROBLEM AFTER THE LEGISLATURE
TO BE RESOLVED. OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS I ACQUIRED IN THE
MEMBER I MEAN IF IT'S EXTRA
COMMITMENT. INCREASING THE
FOCUS ON HOMELESSNESS AND
INCREASING WITHIN THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH IF I COULD PAY FOR THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AND I
THINK THIS BILL MOVES US BOTH
BOTH BOTH MISDIRECTION AGREES
NOT FOCUSED. AND SET THAT UP
FOR FURTHER INCREASES AND NOT
FOCUS ON THE FAMILY MEMBER
MENTION. WITH THAT HI- I THINK
THE BILL IS. QUITE SIMPLE AND-
I'M QUITE GOOD SO I WOULD URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. FOR TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE
GONNA CHECK THE GALLERY AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
EXPRESS ITS SUPPORT POSITION ON
A. B. TWELVE TWENTY SCENE
KNOWING THERE TO TESTIFY. I
WILL CHECK YOUR FULL ROOM TO
ENSURE THERE'S NO WITNESSES
THERE WILL BACK THE MODERATOR
S. A MODERATOR- TO QUEUE UP ANY
SUPPORT FOR A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
ON THE TELECONFERENCE. LINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
GOODNESS CHAIR TO- COMMENTED
JUST OF THE V. TWELVE TWENTY
PER ONE THE NEWS PLEASE. ONCE
AGAIN THE COMMENT OF SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PLEASE CHECK THEM OUT SO
WE GOT NO RESPONSE OKAY THANK
YOU FOR CHECKING THEN WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO IDENTIFY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WANTS TO.
EXPRESS OPPOSITION IN THE
GALLERY HERE TODAY A SCENE
NONE- WE WILL CHECK THE- THE
OTHER ROOM AND THERE'S NO ONE
IN YOUR FORUM TO TESTIFY. A
MODERATE WOULD YOU CHECK AND
SEE IF THERE'S A ANYONE FIVE
CUED UP WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL A. B.
TWELVE TWENTY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIR PROPOSITION A B. TWELVE
TWENTY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. ONCE AGAIN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE B. TWELVE
TWENTY PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR AFTER THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THERE ARE NO
RESPONSE ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR MAKING THE
ANNOUNCEMENT WILL COME BACK TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FIRST TO SEE IF THERE ANY
COMMENTS. IN CENTER CALL THE
EURO. BUT YOU KNOW THE FOURTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR HI I AM A- WHEN I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR- FOR TAKING
TAKING THIS ON LET ME JUST SAY
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
HOPING THAT THIS BILL WILL DO
AND I AM NOT SURE. IT DOES IS
TO FIGURE OUT- TO TASK THIS NEW
ORGANIZATION WITH A- WITH
COLLECTING DATA. SO THAT WE CAN
MEASURE SUCCESS- AND ALSO. WE
CAN LOOK AT. WHAT HIS WORKING
BEST IN WHICH COMMUNITIES SO
THAT WE KNOW WHAT THE BEST
PRACTICES ARE ON. I REPRESENT
SIX COUNTIES AND- PART OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT EVERY COUNTY IS
DOING THINGS ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
THEIR COCS AND I CAN'T GET DATA
ON WELL NUMBER ONE IS WE DO WE
DO OUR- OUR HOMELESS. COUNT AS
A AS A POINT IN TIME AND I'M
NOT SURE THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO
DO IT I'M NOT SURE I HAVE AN
IDEA OF WHAT IS A BETTER WAY
BUT- I DO KNOW THAT THE- THE
POINT ACCOUNT HAS SOME REAL.
CHALLENGES AND I THINK IF YOU
ASKED ANYBODY ON THE STREET
TODAY THEY WOULD SAY THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS GOTTEN WORSE
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE SPENT.
MULTIPLE MILLIONS MULTIPLE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. AND THE MONEY THAT WE
PUT OUT FOR PROJECT ROOM KEY. I
THINK THAT'S THE NAME OF THE
PROJECT. THAT BOUGHT HOTELS
HOTELS AND IS REFURBISHING
THEM. I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY HOUSED
BECAUSE OF THAT AND- SO IT YOU
MIGHT JUST THINK THAT THAT
KEEPING THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT
I KNOW H. CD IS STARTING TO
COLLECT UP- A LOT OF DATA BUT-
THE MORE THAT WE CAN SEE IT
FROM. FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IN
TERMS OF HOW WE ROLL OUT MY
NEED I THINK THE BETTER IT'S
GOING TO BE SO- I'M HOPING THAT
THAT THAT'LL BE ONE OF THE
TASKS AND- I DO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND I THINK IT'S IT IT'S
THEM. WE'VE SET IT UP IS GOOD
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. P. FIFTY
CENT OR ANYONE ELSE ANY OF THE
OTHER SENATORS ON THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO COMMENT ON THE BILL
IF NOT WE CAN ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. CETERA BECAUSE HE MOVES
THE BILL. IT WILL COME BACK TO
THE ALTAR TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS- FROM
YOU- YOU KNOW IT'S TIME THAT WE
RESTRUCTURE AND EMPOWER THIS
COUNCIL TO SERVE AS A STATEWIDE
FACILITATOR AND COORDINATOR ON
OUR HOMELESSNESS AND-
INVESTMENTS YOU KNOW WE YOU
KNOW OUR GOAL IS TEN
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA-
AND- WHILE. YOU KNOW THIS BILL
DOWN DOESN'T MANDATE THE DATA
COLLECTION THERE ARE OTHER
MEASURES CONCURRENTLY I THINK I
BELIEVE YOU HEARD ONE TODAY BY-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL- THAT
IS THE DATA- COLLECTION. PART
OF THE HOMELESSNESS YOU KNOW
THESE TWO BILLS ARE BOTH- B. WE
BOTH HAVE BEEN COLLABORATING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION- AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT BOTH WITH THIS
THIS TAKES CARE OF THE COUNCIL
STRUCTURE. AND THEN THERE'S
ANOTHER BILL THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE STRICT ACCOUNTABILITY
AND DATA COLLECTION- FROM OUR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS- I AGREE
WITH YOU WEAK ACCOUNTABILITY IS
IMPORTANT AND WE NEED TO HAVE
METRICS. OF WENT EVERY YEAR TO
SEE HOW WE ARE PROGRESSING HOW
HOW WHAT ARE WE MAKING PROGRESS
TOWARDS ENDING HOMELESSNESS- SO
I'VE HEARD FROM SO MANY
COLLEAGUES ON THAT AND I THINK
THAT IS. SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
ALL VERY FOCUSED ON END- THE
LEGISLATURE DESERVES TO SEE
THAT RIGHT TO SEE THAT DATA
FROM OUR- OUR INVESTMENTS RIGHT
AND I AGREE WITH YOU- BUT- SO
TODAY I'M JUST ASKING. FOR YOUR
VOTE. ON A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MEMBER- WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITEHOUSE GIVEN THE
BILLS WAS CONSOLED CULTURAL
PLEASE. THIS IS A SUMMARY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REAVIS THE MOTON IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CORTEZ E. CORTEZ HE I'D
BATES. BATES III COPYRIGHT
COPYRIGHT BY ADMIN. EGGMAN I
THANK THEM BY THE BUYER WHAT
SHOULD BOOK A TROUBLED EYES
SCANNER. INNER BY A MEMBER
NUMBER I THINK WE CAN SKI WITH
HUSKY I EIGHT ZERO. OKAY WILL
KEEP THE PHONE CALL FOR THE
OFFICE OF MEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NOW
TO E. B. TWELVE NINETY SEVEN
THE AUTHOR ON THE BILL OF SOME
REMEMBER HOLDEN PRESENTING THE
BILL WILL BE SENATOR O'TOOLE
FOLKS. A MEMBER OF OUR
COMMITTEE OF COURSE SO
OTHERWISE IT WOULD BEEN QUITE A
LONG WAIT BECAUSE SHE'S BEEN
HERE THE WHOLE TIME. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY SENATOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A B.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN TODAY A. B.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WILL
CLARIFY THAT I THANK ME FINANCE
HOUSING IS PART OF IT OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE PROJECT ONLY WHEN THE
HOUSING ELEMENT IS REQUIRED FOR
THE OPERATION OF THE PROJECT.
ADDITIONALLY NO PART OF THE
HOUSING ELEMENT CAN BE FINANCED
WITH TAX EXEMPT BONDS TO ENSURE
THERE'S NO CONFLICT WITH OTHER
STATE HOUSING FINANCE PROGRAMS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW I THINK IS
AUTHORIZED TO FINANCE A WIDE
VARIETY OF PUBLIC AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS BUT
EXPRESSLY EXCLUDES HOUSING
WITHOUT DEFINING THE SCOPE OF
THAT RESTRICTION. CORRECT CLEAR
INDICATION OF WHY. THE ABSOLUTE%
PROHIBITION ON HOUSING IN THE
IPAD ACT CREATES A FINANCING
GAP. BY EXCLUDING ALL PROJECTS
THAT CONTAIN ANY ELEMENT OF
HOUSING. FOR EXAMPLE PROJECTS
THAT HAVE A FACULTY HOUSING FOR
SCHOOL'S GROUNDSKEEPERS OR
OPERATORS FACILITIES SUMMER
YOUTH CAMPS AND TREATMENT
RELATED HOUSING FOR SOCIAL
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS CANNOT BE
FINANCED BY THE BANK. UNDER AB
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN THESE
PROJECTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE. AS
THE FINANCER OF LAST RESORT FOR
MANY PROJECTS THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW ITEMS TO ADD AN IMPORTANT
TOOL IN THE STATE'S TOOL BELT
TO INCREASE MORE TARGETED AND
CREATIVE APPROACHES TO HOUSING.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME AMBER
MADISON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL OKAY
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR WILL GO TO THE LEAD
SUPPORT WITH THIS AT THIS TIME
IF YOU'RE READY YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON ABIT MADISON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. THE I.
BANK ACT PROVIDES CRUCIAL POINT
OF CRUCIAL FINANCING MECHANISM
FOR PUBLIC DEVELOPMENT
FACILITIES THAT SOMETIMES
INCLUDE AN ELEMENT OF HOUSING.
CA IS HERE TO SUPPORT A B.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN BECAUSE IT
WOULD CLARIFY THE AUTHORITY OF
THE I. BANK TO INCLUDE
FINANCING PROJECTS PUT HOUSING
ELEMENTS WHEN THOSE ELEMENTS
ARE NECESSARY FOR THE OPERATION
OF THE FINANCED PROJECT. THIS
CLARIFICATION WILL HAVE THE
EFFECT OF MOVING PROJECTS ALONG
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE BEEN
PROHIBITED. SINCE EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY SEVEN MAKES IT CLEAR
THAT NO PART OF THE HOUSING
ELEMENT CAN BE FINANCED WITH
TAX EXEMPT BONDS. BY CLARIFYING
THE TERM HOUSING UNDER THE I
THINK ACT THIS BILL EXPANDS
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES IN THE
STATE WHILE ENSURING THERE IS
NO CONFLICT WITH OTHER HOUSING
FINANCE PROGRAMS. THEREFORE
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY SEVEN WILL
BE PART OF THE SOLUTION AND
CREATING MORE HOUSING AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TO
CALIFORNIA SO DESPERATELY NEED.
FOR THESE REASONS THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. ACTUALLY REQUEST-
I WROTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I WILL COME.
BACK TO- THIS ROOM AN ASTERISM
IN THE GALLERY WISHES TO
EXPRESS ITS SUPPORT POSITION ON
THIS BILL WOULD BE TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN. WERE SEEN- KNOWN
MOVE TOWARD THE MICROPHONE SO
WE WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM
WAS SEEN ON THERE TO TESTIFY
THE MODERATOR WOULD YOU CHECK
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO QUEUE UP TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR TO TALK TO A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY ONCE
AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. MR SURELY HAVE NO COLLEGE
EDUCATED OKAY THANK YOU FOR
CHECKING MODERATOR WILL COME
BACK TO THE OPPOSITION SIDE.
AND WE NOTE THAT THERE IS NO
IDENTIFY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS ON A. B. TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN SO WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE HERE. IN THE GALLERY
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SEEN NONE AGAIN WE'LL CHECK
YOUR FULL ROOM- THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES THERE TO SPEAK THE
MODERATOR- ONCE AGAIN ON THE B.
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WE'D ASK
YOU TO CHECK. FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. TESTIMONY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ON. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT IN MY PHONE TOO I'M
NOT IN A POSITION OF PUBLIC
SEVEN PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. ONCE
AGAIN THE PROPOSITION TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MR SURELY
HAVE NO CALLERS IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR CHECKING
THEM BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO SEE IF THERE. IS
ANYONE HERE PRESENT WHO WISHES
TO. B. RECOGNIZE SEEN NONE WE
CAN ENTERTAIN A MOTION. ON THE
BILL OF LET ME GIVE CENTER TO A
BOGUS AN OPPORTUNE TO CLOSE
FIRST THEN WE'LL COME BACK FOR
A MOTION SENATOR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I.
PORT. THANK YOU- MOTION FROM
THE FLOOR FROM THE COMMITTEE-
SIX HERE CENTER PROBABLY EURO
THANK YOU FOR THE MOTION. OF
THE BILLS MOVE WAS ONSULTANT-
TO CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. THIS
IS A SUMMARY BILL TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR CORTEZ
E. NINE CORTEZ HE I'D BATES.
BATES HI COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT
BY EGGMAN. EGGMAN I'D REQUIRE A
CHILL BOOK. A TOWBOAT. HI SORRY
I HEARD YOU BUT DIDN'T SEE A
SCANNER. SKINNER I- BURKE
NUMBER FIVE WITH CASKEY HOTELS
K. I. EIGHT ZERO. EIGHT ZERO
AND- WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBER- WE'RE COMING
BACK TO. I BELIEVE OUR FINAL
AUTHOR FINAL BILL TO BE HEARD
TODAY IN COMMITTEE A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS ARIAN IS- OFFER HERE
YET. HE'S THE AUTHORS IN ROUTE.
OKAY WE'RE- CAN A PAUSE NOT
RECESS WE'RE GONNA PAUSE ONE OF
THE ALTAR HERE MOMENTARILY
SOUNDS LIKE.
OKAY THE- THE
AUTHORS HERE WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THIS IS AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. IN THE SOON AS YOU
GET SITUATED- WE'RE READY TO
HEAR YOUR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
THANK YOU SENATORS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY OF
PRESENTING A B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE- THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS LAW ESTABLISHES THAT
THE PURPOSE OF CALIFORNIA'S
BUILDING CODES IS TO PRESERVE.
AND PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY. WHILE CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT BUILDING CODES ARE GOOD
AT KEEPING PEOPLE SAFE IN
EARTHQUAKES ARE CODES DO NOT DO
LITTLE TO PREVENT DAMAGE LIMIT
BUILDING CLOSURE TIMES OR LIMIT
FINANCIAL LOSSES FOR MOST
BUILDINGS. THIS BILL MAYBE
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. HELP
COMMUNITIES RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY FROM DAMAGING
EARTHQUAKES IN THREE WAYS AND
COLLEAGUES SAY YOU'VE BEEN IN A
HEARING FOR A WHILE BUT I WANT
TO DO IS JUST GO OVER THESE
THREE POINTS. AND THEN JUST
FOCUS ON A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WERE. IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
I WANTED TO CORRECT AND THEN
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. SO- THREE THINGS IT
CLARIFIES THAT ARE BUILDING
CODE IS MEANT TO SUPPORT
RECOVERY AS WELL AS SAFETY. TO
PROTECT LIVELIHOODS AS WELL AS
LINES. IT ALSO IT ALLOWS CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO AMEND THE STATE
CODE TO ADDRESS. RECOVERY AS A
LOCAL PRIORITY- IT CHARGES THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO SET THE MINIMUM
STATEWIDE REQUIREMENTS RELATED
TO POST EARTHQUAKE RECOVERY.
AND THE AS FOR SOME OF THE JUST
TO CLARIFY A COUPLE OF POINTS
IN THE ANALYSIS SPECIFICALLY ON
PAGE FOUR. THE SENTENCE THAT TO
AT THE END OF PARAGRAPH THREE
STATES A FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY
STANDARD WOULD IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD ALSO RESULT IN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN UPFRONT
COSTS OF CONSTRUCTION. THAT'S
NOT. QUITE ACCURATE- WE HAVE-
DATA ACCORDING TO THE FEE
MINUS. THIRTY OF A OF A OF JUST
THIS YEAR FEBRUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- WE HAVE DATA THAT
INDICATES MANY BUILDINGS WILL
EXPERIENCE NO OR YOU KNOW
RELATIVELY VERY SMALL INCREASE-
CONSTRUCTION COSTS TO MEET
FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY BUILDING
STANDARDS. AND OTHERS THAT WILL
BE AS LITTLE AS OF BETWEEN ONE
TO. 3% AS STATED IN THE FEW
MINISTRY PORT IN FACT A RECENT
AWARD WINNING A FOUR DOUBLE
HOUSING PROJECT IN SAN
FRANCISCO WAS DESIGNED. AND
CONSTRUCTED TO PROVIDE IMPROVED
RECOVERY TIMES FOR LESS THAN
HALF THE PERCENT POINT
INCREASE. AGAIN ON PAGE FIVE
THERE'S A STATEMENT REFERRING
TO A PRESENTATION FROM THE
CALVO CONFERENCE. WHICH IS
AGAIN SOMEWHAT UT OF CONTEXT-
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
ENVISIONS AN ENTIRELY NEW. IT
READS- THE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH ENVISIONS AN ENTIRELY
NEW DESIGN STANDARDS BASED ON
RECENT AND ONGOING RESEARCH AND
VETTED BY EXPERT COMMITTEES IT
IS ESTIMATED THAT THIS APPROACH
WOULD TAKE TEN PLUS YEARS. THIS
PART OF THE PRESENTATION HAS
BEEN- TAKEN SOMEWHAT OUT OF
CONTEXT AND IS NOT WHAT IS
ENVISIONED BY EP THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. THE PRESENTATION
AT THE COUPLE CONFERENCE WIZARD
DISCUSSING HOW THE APPROACH TO
FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY COULD BE
EITHER. SIMPLE OR COMPREHENSIVE
THE PROCESS OUTLINED IN THIS
BILL IS THE SIMPLE VERSION
BECAUSE IT JUST ASKS. A B. S.
C. THE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION TO GO FORWARD AND DO
THIS RATHER HAVE THE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH WHICH
WOULD HAVE BROUGHT MANY
DIFFERENT AGENCIES. TO DO IT
AND AT A GREATER COST AND ALSO
GREATER TIMELINE- SO WITH THAT
A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE IS-
CONSISTENT WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
AND- THE SAME REPORT BY
FEMALENESS. AND WILL GIVE US
THE BUILDING CODES THAT REFLECT
OUR SHARED PRIORITIES AND NEEDS
IN TERMS OF SAFETY AND RECOVERY
HAVING BUILDINGS SUFFERED
DAMAGE THAT WILL REQUIRE COSTLY
REPAIRS AND LENGTHY DOWNTIME.
UNTIL THOSE REPAIRS ARE MADE
WILL HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATELY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT LACKED THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO PAY FOR
THOSE REPAIRS AND FOURTEEN
MAKE. TEMPORARY ARRANGEMENTS
FOR HOUSING EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT FOR THOSE REPAIRS
ARE MADE- A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE HELPS TO SET HIGHER
STANDARDS FOR RECOVERY BASED
PERFORMANCE. THAT WILL HELP
PROTECT THESE COMMUNITIES FROM
THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
EARTHQUAKES WITH ME IS. RYAN
KERSTING A- LICENSE CALIFORNIA
STRUCTURAL ENGINEER WHO IS
TODAY REPRESENTING THE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
WHO HAS. ALSO BEEN THE CHAIR OF
THE COMMITTEE OF EXPERTS FOR
THE RECENTLY RELEASED FEDERAL
REPORT ON THIS TOPIC. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MEMBER AND- MR RANCOR
STING- YOU MAY PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY FROM THE GALLERY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE I AM RYAN
KERSTING APRAKSIN STRUCTURAL
HERE SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF OVER THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS. OF THE STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE EXPERTS WHEN
IT COMES TO UNDERSTANDING
EARTHQUAKE PERFORMANCE OF
BUILDINGS. THE PANDEMIC
WILDFIRE AND OTHER HAZARD
OFFENSIVE TAUGHT US ABOUT THE
RECOVERY AND ABOUT THE SERVICES
THAT ARE NEEDED TO IMPROVE
RECOVERY. IN THE PANDEMIC MANY
OF THESE SERVICES HAVE BEEN
GIVEN THE TITLE IS ESSENTIAL.
BUT IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
BUILDING CODES MANY OF THOSE
SAME BUILDINGS ARE NOT BEING
DESIGNED AS SUCH. WE HAVE SEEN
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE BUILDINGS AND
SERVICES. HOWEVER UNDER THE
CURRENT CODE SUCH BUILDINGS
WOULD LIKELY BE CLOSE FOR MANY
MONTHS AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE IN
ORDER TO BE REPAIRED. IF NOT
FULLY REVEALS BEFORE BEING RE
OPENS. THE RECENTLY RELEASED
FEDERAL REPORT RECOGNIZES THE
NEED FOR AN EFFECTIVE PURGES
STATE AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO PURSUE FUNCTION RECOVERY
STANDARDS IN THEIR BUILDING
CODES. WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS CALLING FOR.
THERE'S A CONSENSUS ACROSS THE
BREADTH OF THE INDUSTRY GROUPS-AND WITHIN VARIOUS LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENTS. THAT WE SHOULD BE
DESIGNER BUILDINGS RECOVERY NOT
JUST SAFETY. WE HAVE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AND STATE
AGENCIES ASKING FOR THIS TYPE
OF PERFORMANCE FOR THEIR
BUILDINGS ALREADY. HOWEVER WE
NEED YOUR HELP TO ESTABLISH A
PATH FOR US TO PARTNER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION. TO FURTHER THE
CONVERSATION AND IMPLEMENT
APPROPRIATE PROVISIONS WITHIN
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING CODE.
AS A SIMILAR MENTIONED THERE IS
A SIMPLE APPROACH THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED. THAT TAKES
ADVANTAGE OF PROVISIONS ALREADY
AVAILABLE TO US THAT WILL NOT
REQUIRE EXTENSIVE EFFORT BY THE
STATE AGENCIES. LIKEWISE A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE IS NOT
EXPECTED TO SIGNIFICANTLY
CHANGE THE COST OF CONSTRUCTION.
THIS IS AN EXCITING OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE A BILL. AND ECHOED THE
PRIORITIZING BUILDINGS IN TERMS
OF WHEN THEY NEED TO BE
FUNCTIONAL AFTER AN EARTHQUAKE.
WE KNOW HOW TO DO BETTER. BUT
NOW WE ACTUALLY NEED TO START
TO DO BETTER. HELP US MAKE THIS
CHANGE WHAT THE STATE DESERVES
THE ARGUS PRADA SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL. WE REQUEST
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'VE HEARD FROM
MISTER CHRISTINE JUST NOW IN
THE GALLERIES OR ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY WISHES TO EXPRESS
THE SUPPORT POSITION. ON THIS
BILL AB THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. A
SINGLE AND MOVED TO THE
MICROPHONE. I WILL CHECK YOUR
FULL ROOM SO YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE- GOING TO GO BACK TO
OUR MODERATOR AND S. MODERATOR.
AT THE POLICE CHECK THE LINE.
FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE STATE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE. ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE. AND LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE FOUR QUESTIONS IN QUEUE IN
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU.
PROCEED INTO OUR FIRST QUESTION
THAT'S LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS THIS IS BOB
RAYMER BUT THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND ALSO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION AND THE
BUILDING OWNERS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION AND WHILE WE'RE NOT
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
HIS STAFF- AND THE SPONSORS.
FOR HELPING US TO GET TO THIS
POINT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIND. ONE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN TOM SHEEHY
REPRESENTING OMEGA FLEX WE LIKE
TO THINK THE AUTHOR OF THIS
BILL FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ONE SIXTY ONE SIX
ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN THING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COUNCIL OF ENGINEERING
COMPANIES CALIFORNIA SPORT
THANK FOR MUCH. ONE FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARC CHRISTIAN WITH THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS CALIFORNIA CAN
SUPPORT. WITH THAT THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES AND SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU FOR THAT-
WILL GO TO THE- OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO BEAT OPPOSITION
IDENTIFIED BACK TO THE GALLERY.
I SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
LAST CALL- WE MOVED TO. THE
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE'S NO ONE
THERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
OF MODERATOR WILL ASK YOU TO.
QUEUE UP. THE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF TELECONFERENCE ON
A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU THE STATE OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
NO WE HAVE NO LINES IN Q. OR A
MONITOR THANK YOU FOR CHECKING
IN- IN THANK YOU OVERALL FOR AN
EXCELLENT JOB TODAY- WE'RE
GOING TO- COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANY OF THE CENTERS ARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WHO WISH TO.
ADDRESS ANYTHING REGARDING THE
BILL CENTER WHY KASKI YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR HAVE A
QUESTION YOU KNOW THE STAFF
REPORT IS AN EXCELLENT JOB
LAYING OUT THE HISTORY OF THIS
LEGISLATION PREVIOUS
RENDITIONS. I'D LIKE TO FOCUS
IN ON THE ROLE OF THE
LEGISLATURE STATUTORILY SETTING
STANDARDS FOR SISTER AGENCY
SETTING REGULATIONS I'M ON PAGE
THREE AND TALKING ABOUT IF WE
SET A STATUTE IF WE SET BY
STATUTE REGULATIONS IT PREVENTS
STATE AGENCIES FROM TAKING AN
EXPERT IN PUBLIC REPORT AND
SORT OF TWEAKING IT WOULD HAVE
TO COME BACK AND DO ANOTHER
SAID. STATUTE AND IT'S IT IT
INDICATES THAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY WISH TO CONSIDER AMENDING
THE BILL TO STRICTER
REQUIREMENT THAT H. E. D. E. N.
THE CBSE TO DEVELOP ADOPT
APPROVE CODIFIED AND PUBLISHED
A FUNCTIONAL RECOVERY STANDARDS
SO IN INSTEAD OF DOING THAT AS
THE BILL IS RIGHT NOW IT WOULD
HAVE THEM DEVELOP AND PROPOSE
SUCH A STANDARD- I'D LIKE TO
ADD AUTHOR TO CLARIFY. WHICH IS
IT- HELLO I SEE FEE WITH. TO
THE QUESTION. HAPPY TO- WILL
OPEN. I THINK I WELL FIRST OF
ALL I'D WANT TO HEAR WHAT- RYAN
RYAN'S TAKE WOULD BE ON THIS I.
WOULD ASSUME THAT- WE WOULDN'T
THE GOAL OF THIS WAS TO TAKE
STEPS TO MAKE SURE THAT- THE
LEGISLATURE GIVES THE DIRECTION
AND THE REGULATION COMES FROM
THE EXPERTS BUT- I'D LIKE TO
HEAR A RYAN'S- RAINS RESPONSE
MR KERR SENIOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RESPOND TO THE QUESTION YES
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION- THIS
BILL THE LANGUAGES BILL
ACTUALLY FOLLOWS THE PRECEDENT
ESTABLISHED BY A NUMBER OF
OTHER BILLS HAVE BEEN PASSED
RETURNING GREEN BUILDING
STANDARDS ELECTRIFICATION-
SOLAR VEHICLE CHARGING STATION
SO WE'RE USING LANGUAGE IS
CONSISTENT WITH PAST BILLS HAVE
BEEN PASSED- AND ACTUALLY THE
LANGUAGES BILLS NOT SETTING THE
STANDARD IS JUST CHARGING THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
TO TAKE THAT EXPERT TESTIMONY
TO TAKE INDUSTRY AND
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND TO
CONSULT WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AS THEY DEVELOP AND
ADOPT THESE STANDARDS THANK YOU
CENTER RIGHT BECAUSE YEAH I
WOULD SAY YOU MISS CHAIR THAT
IN AN ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION FOR
THAT WERE EVERY WE'RE CLEAR IS
THAT THE S. PROPOSED BY THE
STAFF REPORT THAT THE AUTHOR
WOULD BE TAKING THOSE
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE. WE'RE
NOT TAKING A- YEAH. EIGHT NINE.
LET ME ASSIST THE OFFER TO
RESPOND DIRECTLY TO THAT IF YOU
WILL. SO THE ANSWER THE
QUESTION IS WHETHER OR NOT I'M
GOING TO TAKE AN AMENDMENT. TO
MAKE THIS CHANGE OR NOT. YEP
I'M I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE I DON'T THINK THESE
AMENDMENTS WERE EVER SUGGEST
THAT AT LEAST I DON'T REMEMBER.
HAVING THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH
STAFF WAS IT. SUGGESTED. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS
AFTER CONSULTATION WITH STAFF
AND- I CAN POTENTIALLY DO IT IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE AS IT MOVES
FORWARD BUT LET ME HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY ALSO TO HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE CONSULTATIONS
BEFORE THINK COMMITTING MYSELF
TO IT RIGHT NOW IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH EVERYONE. RIGHT HERE- THE
AUTHOR SAYING HE WILL WORK WITH
HIS COMMITTEE STAFF THE NEXT
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THE
MEMBERS THAT WERE SUGGESTED IN
THE ANALYSIS IS A- FIRST YES.
YES HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU
THANK YOU CENTER WHY BECAUSE HE
SEEMS TO BE- SATISFIED WITH
THAT SIR MICHAEL SKI SAW THE
FORWARD CURVE HE DONE OKAY
THANK YOU THE CENTER CALL THE
EURO. I'M I A I WENT- IT MAY.
COMMAND THE OFFER IT THE AUTHOR
FOR. AT LEAST HAVING THE
CONVERSATION IT'S THE SAME
ISSUE THAT I RAISED IN- A BILL
THAT CAME HERE EARLIER. I'M IT
SEEMS TO ME LIKE WE WERE
DIRECTING- AT THE- SAME
ORGANIZATION THE- BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION- AND
RATHER THAN ASKING THEM TO USE
THEIR EXPERTISE AND SO I
APPRECIATE THAT- I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
WE'LL SEE. WHAT WE CAN HAVE
MORE OF A DISCUSSION. I THINK-
WITH YOU AS IF YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS OR NOT WE
SHOULD PROBABLY HAVE THAT
FOLLOW UP DISCUSSIONS. I'M
HAPPY TO THINK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN OKAY
THANK YOU SENATOR ANYONE ELSE-
WISHING TO ADDRESS ANYTHING AT
THIS TIME. FROM THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SPECIFICALLY
THAT SAID. WE WILL ASKED THE
OFFICER. IF HE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE THANK YOU. OKAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL AND IN
WORKING ON THE- LANGUAGE THAT
HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED RIGHT
UNDERSTOOD WE APPRECIATE YOU
PUTTING THAT ON THE RECORD
THANK YOU- WE DO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
BUT SIR WHAT BECAUSE HE IS
MOVING THE BILL- SO THE BILLS
MOVE WAS CONSOLE MCCALL THE
ROLE. THIS IS A SUMMARY BILL
THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE BY A
FAMILY MEMBER IN THIS AREA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CORTEZ
C. CORTEZ HE I'D BATES. IT'S
NOW COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT BY
EGGMAN. EGGMAN I REQUIRE A
TROUBLED A TROUBLED NOW SKINNER
SKINNER I AM BURKE A BIRD'S-EYE
CASKEY. BECAUSE THE I. SIX TO
TWO. THREE SIXTY TWO- WE'LL
HAVE TO KEEP IT ON CALL- WE
EXPECTED TO LIFT THE CALL
SHORTLY- BUT WE'LL GO ON FILE
ORDER- FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SO AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. THAT CONCLUDES OUR
V. THE BILLS AND FOLLOW ORDERS
THAT WE- WERE SET TO HEAR
TODAY- IF WE DO NEED TO CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS- AND I'D LIKE TO
GO ON FILE ORDER. I KNOW WE'RE
WAITING FOR AN ABSENT MEMBER TO
ARRIVE STILL. YEAH WE WILL GO
AHEAD IN- IF YOU CAN GIVE
EVERYONE WHO IS HERE PRESENT
THAT THAT NEEDS TO VOTE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO I WILL
START WITH THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR A CONSULTANT IF YOU
CAN. FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THERE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS.
TO SIX SEVEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
AND SIXTEEN SENATOR REQUIRE.
BUT SHOW BOTH. THIS IS
CONSIDERED SECOND OWNER WHAT
TROUBLE I SCANNER SCANNER HI.
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO WE'LL
KEEP IT ON CALL FOR THE OFFICE
OF MEMBER NO- IT'S ONLY A FEW.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE NEXT
BILL ON FILE ORDER PHONE NUMBER
ONE. THE B. FOURTEEN OH ONE
THIS IS A SUMMARY BILL FORTINO
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT THAT IS
FIVE TO TWO. SENATOR REQUIRE.
UMBERG AMBER DACH BETTING.
STILL FIVE TO TWO. THANK YOU
BOTH TO WILL KEEP ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBER WORLD NUMBER
TWO A. B. SIXTY EIGHT AUTHOR
CORK SILVER. THAT TIME CONCEPT
I'M SORRY THAT WAS ON CONSENT
MY APOLOGIES- THE NEXT PHONE
NUMBER IS OTHER PERKS OVER THE
V. PHONE NUMBER THREE IN THE
CORRECT A BILL NUMBERS A. B.
THREE SIXTY TWO I APOLOGIZE FOR
THE MISSTATEMENT THIS IS THE
SUM ABOUT THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT THAT IS
SIX ZERO. SENATOR BATES. IT'S
NOT BURNING. ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SIXTY TWO FILE ITEM.
THREE BUT IT'S NOT VOTING
MCGUIRE. STILL SIX ZERO. OKAY
SIX OH AND WE'LL KEEP IT ON
CALL THE ITEM PHONE NUMBER FOR-
THIS IS A. B. FIVE SIXTY ONE
TEAM WAS THE AUTHOR. THIS IS A
SOME ABOUT FIVE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANK THE MOTIONIS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT POTUS FIVE TO TWO.
SENATOR EDMUND. EGGMAN I
REQUIRE. SIX TO KEEP THEM CLEAN
THE MOVE TO- A FILE ITEM FIVE.
THIS IS A B. SIX OH TWO AUTHORS
GRAYSON. THIS IS A SEMI BILL
SIX OH TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE. STILL EIGHT
ZERO. OKAY THANK YOU THE MOVE
TO ITEM SIX HIM SIX SYMBOL.
SEVENTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS I'M
SORRY- SCRATCH THAT STRIKE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ITEM
EIGHT WHICH IS THE SYMBOL NINE
EIGHTY NINE GABRIEL. THIS IS
THE SUM OF ALL NINE EIGHTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT POTUS
FIVE ZERO SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI. SIX OF. THAT'S DONE
SO THE BILLS OUT. WE WILL MOVE
TO FOLLOW HIM NINE AUTHORS
LEVIN AB NINE SIXTY FIVE THIS
IS THE SUM OF THE NINE SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST%
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR EDMUND.
EGGMAN II. EIGHT ZERO. THE BILL
IS OUT TO DO SO THANK YOU. THE
ITEM TEN. MAYBE TEN FORTY THREE
AUTHORS BRIAN. THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FORTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SEVEN ACQUIRE
REQUIRED HI NINE ZERO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT THE BILL IS
ULTIMATE WEAPON. AB TWELVE
TWENTY AUTHOR REAVIS THIS IS A
SUMMARY BILL TWELVE TWENTY BY
SOME REMEMBER REVERSE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
ACQUIRE HI NINE NOW THE BILLS
OUT THE BILL IS A ROOM TWELVE
AB. TWELVE NINETY SEVEN AUTHORS
HOLDEN. THIS IS THE SUM ABOUT
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE II NINE ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT READ THE BILLS OUT ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE IS ARIAN IS THE AUTHOR.
THIS IS THE SUM OF ALL THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY SELLING MEMBERS
IN THIS AREA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE. CHOIR I
SEVENTY TWO THE BILL IS OUT.
READ THOSE OUT. WELL WE'RE
GONNA COME BACK TO THE TOP OF
THE FILE ORDER BUT AGAIN WE'RE
GONNA START WITH CONSENT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE- WE STILL
HAVE CONSENT ON CALL. THIS IS A
GOOD SECOND- WHICH CONSISTS OF
FILE ITEMS. TO SIX SEVEN
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN
SOME OF THEM REQUIRE. MCGUIRE I.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO TWO SENT-
CALENDARS OUT. THE NEXT INFO
ORDER PHONE NUMBER ONE.
ASSEMBLE FORTINO ONE FRIEDMAN
IS THE AUTHOR THIS IS A
SELLABLE FORTINO ONE BY SOME
MEMBER MEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT THAT IS
FIVE TO TWO SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI SIXTY TWO. THE BILL
IS OUT THE BILLS UP TO MOVE TO-
FILE. ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
THREE SIXTY TWO AUTHOR QUIRK
SILVA. THIS ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE. ACQUIRE HI
SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
READ THE BILLS OUT. OF ITEM FOR
AB FIVE SIXTY ONE OF THIRTEEN.
THIS IS A SUBURB OF FIVE SIXTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TANK THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR REQUIRE.
REQUIRE HI SEVENTY TWO THAT
BILL IS OUT. THE BILL IS A TERM.
I FOR FOLLOWING FIVE ZB SIX OH
TWO AUTHORS GRAYSON. THIS IS
THE SUM OF ALL SIX OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE.
ACQUIRE HI NINE ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT THE BILL SO- CONSOLE NOT
BELIEVE THAT THAT CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA FOR TODAY ALL FILE ITEMS
ARE. ACCOUNTED FOR. I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED
IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. A
NOTE THAT IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY THERE'S ANY PROBLEMS
GETTING THROUGH TODAY. A WEEK
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
HOUSE. A COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
INCLUDING YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS- THAT-
IS WHERE THEY WOULD BE CAPPED.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION ONE EXTEND MY
PERSONAL PROFESSIONAL THANKS.
TO THE COMMITTEE STUFF TODAY
FOR ALL THEIR SUPPORT- AND FOR
EVERYONE'S COOPERATION TODAY
AND GET AN ANSWER ALONG GENDER.
THANK YOU. WE ARE CHURNED.